[Music]
mm-hmm
oh
[Music]
uh
foreign
[Music]
um
my
hmm
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
welcome everybody to the live coverage
of the 2015 london chess classic this is
the final tournament of the 2015 grand
chess tour definitely the most important
trio of tournaments this year we are
going to be starting very soon here from
london as we should see the players
arrive in just a second
i am grand master alejandra ramirez here
with grand master pastor sarah one
always good to see you alejandra welcome
aboard always a pleasure to be here so
yeah sir what it's really classic what a
thrilling final event we've got in store
i'm just expecting a great tournament
and as everybody's jockeying for
position for the 150 dollar bonus pool
and to be
you know bragging rights to say you're
the grand slam
a grand chess tour winner that's just
going to be great and to see what they
need let's look at the standings
currently after two
at tournaments
top is still vesseling topple up after
his win in norway and a decent
performance here in saint louis now a
very stable player hikaru nakamura has
gotten third and two events and he sits
in second
uh levona rodian won here in st louis
but he had a disastrous start in norway
therefore he's still in third place one
point behind nakamura and just one point
behind aronian is magnus carlson who
managed to recover from a very tough
norway into a somewhat decent saint
louis tournament finishing on second and
only one point behind him is the very
solid player aneesh geary
with 13 points just slightly below is
fishy and on with 12 as well as vaccine
bashir lagrav with a combination of
results either of these players can
still take the entire grand chess tour
and trailing behind them are going to be
fabiano carrana and alexander gristrops
would be more of a miracle to actually
finish in the top plays but anything can
happen they're very strong players and i
like to see them recover definitely oh
for for sure and for me
i mean it magnus carlson the world
champion so for so many years has
dominated chess and the miracle
comebacks that magnus has shown
a proclivity for has just been uh
amazing so for me
you know even though magnus is in fourth
position as we start the london classic
i still look for him to pull off
you know a hail mary win at the end
we'll see if he's going to be able to do
so with the pairings for today we have
grand master maurice ashley
well it's absolutely a magnificent time
for chess it's the holiday season what
more would you want them to be watching
the best tournament in the world with
the best players buying it out for the
title of the grand chess tour champ well
there's going to be a lot of work to do
in round one just started off right away
we see that vasilyn topolov and gear
will be battling you're looking at a
pairing
carlson versus vashea lagrave that's
going to be an important one magnus
carlson he's been playing horribly this
year he's tanked in rating points it's
been a miserable year by his lofty
standards he's gonna have to do a lot
and he wants to do it right out the gate
but the matchup to paulov geary as i
mentioned this one will be a key one as
topalov is at the top of the leaderboard
he is number one in the in the whole
chess tour but against this youngster
he's only three and three is an even
match up and gary this guy doesn't lose
he just doesn't seem to want to lose any
games against the best players so this
would be a very tough fight we'll keep
our eye on this great matchup and then
many more of course as the grand chess
store kicks off here in london the final
leg
trying to find out the champion finally
at last
guys
and alejandra i just want to say i don't
think gary has lost
on tour i mean he's drawn or won i mean
that's just incredible he's definitely a
very solid player has not lost in the
entire grand chess tour fortunately for
him he hasn't accumulated that many
victories so he hasn't won either one of
the tournaments but yeah he's undefeated
he's the only player that's still
undefeated in the entire grand chester
that's a remarkable stat right there wow
that's just incredible absolutely and
speaking of london we have live from
london
our own very own woman's grandmaster
jennifer shahadi
hey guys thanks that's right i'm here in
london on the final and third leg of the
grand chess tour
the london chess classic i'm going to be
here on the ground for the next couple
weeks really excited to see
not only who's going to win the
tournament but who's going to come on
top of the first ever grand chess tour
let's get it started
well the rounds should be starting very
soon and i wanted to talk a little bit
about some of the players that are here
in this tournament i think that a lot of
them have had by their standards a very
rough year yes this is true i want to
see how they finish up we're talking
about for example fabiano caruana oh
brutal he had a brutal year and he's
just recovering he had an excellent
match here against hikaru nakamura it
doesn't reflect on the world's standings
because it wasn't rated but definitely
he showed excellent chess and i think
maybe on the path to recovery well when
you think about it he once reached the
peak of 2851 on the live ratings and
he's dropped below 2800 this is
that's incredible that's a disaster and
he's actually seventh in the world right
now not from second and a clear second
he was the one that was yes so that's
been uh terrible
but the one player strangely enough
who's been at the top number two and
very stable
is wrestling topolof why
because he
doesn't play he's only been playing on
the grand chest store where he's done
quite well as we know he's the
tournament leader and there we get a
look at the kings and then
olympia
building where the match as well as a
lot of chess events are being played
right we have several amateur chess
events being played at the same time we
have on camera uh peter hein nielsen and
harry carlson the coach of magnus
carlson and the father of magnus carlsen
respectively exactly they seem to just
look at the crowd
as they're trying to go into the playing
hall right they're all waiting for their
chance to get into the playing hall and
playing hall start to fill up soon as a
lot of those
events amateur events
are completed it's 4 p.m
local time in london
and the match as well the games will
start at 4 during the weekdays and at 2
london time on the weekends
yeah nice little change there of
schedule i think the players will have
trouble adjusting to that absolutely no
seriously as a as a chess grandmaster i
really hated even one round
they always did that in europe they had
the last rounds that started early so
they could get enough time in for the
closing ceremony and it really threw off
your biorhythms if you will you know
you're on a schedule on a certain type
of pace and you have to change for the
weekends
absolutely i think that having that
consistency is very important and
sometimes when you're really in the
schedule really in the mood and then
somehow you have to change yeah it's
disconcerting it was just a little
detail but it is disconcerting without
the question having the rounds change
two hours earlier will be tomorrow will
be two hours earlier right precisely
that's what i mean then i'll be on
sunday and then two hours later on
monday it's gonna be a little bit
difficult for the players i think
to
adjust i think to the schedule well one
of the things that i thought was very
interesting during the sinkfield cup is
that we were interviewed maurice was
interviewing with alexander grishock and
he was saying
you know sasha what how's it going and
things like this and he was mentioning
that he was he had done some preparation
right up into the round
right and then suddenly you know if
you've got a two-hour window where that
doesn't exist it could be very impactful
now in terms of the chess though
alejandro i mean nobody's saving it i
mean this is an important event it's the
inaugural
tour
the players are going to be playing
their best stuff they're not holding
back for anything like the candidates i
would imagine we're going to see some
really
assimilating novelties and i'm looking
forward to some really great encounters
no i definitely expected it's not only
an important tournament it's going to be
the one that determines the final
standing precisely and speaking of these
top players maurice actually has an
update for us on their current live
ratings
well we're at the site 20 700 chess.com
it keeps us up to date on what the
ratings are if the best players in the
world as they play this will go live
when the tournament begins as the games
go on and then they'll update as soon as
it's over we see number one is magnus
carlsen right at the top at 28 34 by his
standards that's horrible i mean this
guy's been up to 28.80
and a little bit higher in fact and now
with 2834 his rating has tumbled playing
in some team events it's just really
dropped dramatically we see also topalov
at 2803 he was up after norway up in the
lofty area of 2820. now he's barely
above 200 the only player above 2800 at
this moment we see vishwanathan anand
who was also once number two up at the
28 20 mark he's down to 28 27 96 kramnik
who's not playing in the tour ikaru
nakamura 2793 also was in the 28-16
range
you see caruana at one point his live
rating was 28.51
i mean think about that how much he's
tumbled since his amazing tournament
last year at the singfield cup here in
saint louis and anish geary a bit down
he also was very close i think he had
broken 2800 a bit uh i skipped aronian
at number six he also dropped from 2830
now down to 27.88 but that's actually a
comeback because he'd been down as well
once number two in the world uh so
anishka vashya lagrav another player who
was i think he was down to 27 30 this
year which was kind of ridiculous but
now he's up to 27.73 he's on a hot
streak he's rising rapidly and gristrok
all the way down here at number 17 he
was once top 10. he's now at 27 47 again
having some terrible results it's been
interesting at the grand chester where
we've seen a lot of battles but in other
events these players have been fighting
in these team events and other
tournaments that's been getting a big
knock on their rating as other players
are starting to surge as well the final
player to mention is grandmaster michael
adams of course mickey the london
favorite uh
player the homegrown boy he's certainly
going to be looking to see if he can
take a bite out of crime in this
tournament
yeah you might be wondering where this
rating goes right if the top players are
losing rating where is it going where
did the points get sprinkled around
right and it's actually very interesting
to see this list compared to a few
months ago because there used to be a
very clear divide between number 10 and
number 11 and the rest it used to be
about a 20 point gap right it was like
27 70 to 27.50 and it was just really
hard but nowadays you say it's much more
gradual and we see a lot of players that
are breaking into this 2760 range more
players into the 2750 uh we have for
example pavel elianov who won and
brilliantly unbelievable amount of
rating in the last couple of events
especially in the world cup going from
what's you know from a normal super
grand master to wow almost top 10 in the
world exactly and it's amazing that you
know these players who really are very
strong sometimes need a little bit of
luck a little bit of push to be able to
actually get there into the top ten well
exactly and what you mentioned that
chasing pack that's kind of narrowing in
the gap and catching up but also don't
forget these juniors these juniors keep
coming up and up and they're underrated
look at we ye you know from china he's
coming up and by the way the you see the
players uh being escorted in the playing
hall there's henrik uh father of magnus
carlson vichy in the yellow
uh and of course lavon aronian always
with the fashion statement you know
they've got to love those shirts
gotta love it
alexander grisham
vladimir tukmakov which is gary's
culture which is anish gary's coach we
saw anish
getting ready for the action and by the
way just to mention because i think it's
quite important is the time control
for this event as we know
it's two hours and 40 minutes without
the increment
not even magnus carlson knew that one in
round one of the norway chess
it cost him 40 moves in two hours
followed by an hour for the entire game
uh with a 30 second bonus increment from
41. it's a very unusual time control yes
it's something that the players are not
really used to even though they've
already had two tournaments it's still
not the classical time control that
they're used to in shash tournaments
and that actually cost magnus carlos in
a game and some say the entire
tournament investment
yes exactly
in a completely winning position the
world champion flagged
thinking that he was going to get extra
time on route 60 but he didn't and he
just let his time expire i'm inspired
yeah it was a remarkable thing to watch
we were there we were all
in open jawed amazement
maurice your thoughts
that made me think about the idea of
magnus not
having to play toppolov again in round
one i remember he played him twice and i
believe he lost twice yes to toppo so
he's thinking all right the tournament's
already off to a good start i don't have
to play that guy right away i'll get him
later
but certainly that time control i find
quite amusing when people say this time
control is unusual is of course
yasser back in the old days
we used to play 40 moves in two hours
all the time is a very normal time
control in fact it was uh an
abbreviation abbreviated time control as
compared to the 40 moves in two and a
half hours that it used to be that they
used to play on a 40 and two was like
the quick time control almost nowadays
of course you have increments we did not
have that uh back in the 80s or the 90s
and the players now are so used to
increments that when they look at their
clock you're thinking i'm gonna move and
get extra time so that that reflex does
affect their performance knowing that
they will not get any extra time it
means that you have to manage your clock
properly of course we've seen grizz
chuck just do horribly at this
particular time control he never manages
his clock well we know he's a great
blitz champion again winning the world
blitz championship this year back in
berlin
but it does not help him it seems in
this tournament although he didn't have
such a horrible result here in st louis
when he played so we'll see if they can
manage the clock properly we see mal
campaign which was just magically on the
screen and disappeared
malcolm payne
is the organizer of the london chess
classic a wonderful organizer doing
great things not just with this
tournament but also with their chess in
the schools program and he's on stage
now as the players it seems are casually
in the front row before they are
escorted onto the stage
i think they'll just uh doing some
speech making and then they'll do the
individual introductions while they're
doing that one of the things that we
could also talk about
is the wild cards so each event so far
uh as had a single wild card in norway
of course it was the norwegian player
jan ludwig hammer though he did qualify
from to make it that's right and wesley
so was our wild card here uh in the
sinkhole cup and then in london we have
the veteran britain's number one
mickey adams who's a real crowd pleaser
very very savvy combative veteran
he's looking to make a couple of upsets
you know and say hey wait a minute i may
be the wild card but i sure have
nobody's pushover either and he's going
to be playing vichyanan somebody that
he's been playing since before i was
born and since before some of the
participants of this tournament was born
they played their first game in 1986.
that doesn't seem so long ago to me just
a second i mean i remember that game was
an oh come wasn't it where they played
the
junior european junior championships
that was great
and i've known i've known both of these
players for decades
and one of the remarkable thing is in
their individual matchup my gosh you
could write three volume set of the
games that they've played each other
they know each other backwards and
forwards that vishy
i was really surprised
uh statistically how well vishy has done
and share with the audience you've got
it right in front of you there it seems
like vishyanam would be the one that
would write the book we will review the
author right i see it's uh 19 and seven
against 19 wins mickey adams but with 36
draws so a very high draw count that
being said 19 wins is only longest
it's quite a remarkable score to have
against any player
i mean there's been a lot of thrashings
between top players i can recall
kasparov and shiroff being one of the
classicals recently in carlson nakamura
talking about thrashings that's even
maybe even worse yeah but i mean adam
says 19 to 7 is still pretty bad yeah
but at least
mickey's got the seven think about
hikaru he hasn't even got the one he's
on schneider are we still talking about
it will be this tournament well
we'll have to see we'll have to see
maurice actually has an opinion on it
well let's not denigrate michael adams
too much when you look at this list he's
number 20 on the list the live list 20th
in the world we talked about about the
wild cards of course uh general hammer
he was not even in top 40 50 players in
the world when he played in norway
wesley saw of the united states he
clearly is a top 10 player and on the
list now he's at number nine so he
certainly deserved the wild card
standing and could have just been seeded
into the tournament before if his rating
had just been a little bit higher he had
been knocked out when they chose just
slipped below the top ten when they
chose the players here
but michael adams at 20th is only three
places below grizzchuk so hey he says i
belong this is not a tournament where he
expects to be completely out class he's
played these players before and
certainly seven wins against viswanathan
anand
that's still seven times he he
you know got some blood he drew some
blood so anand knows that he can
definitely lose to this opponent all the
games are going to be contentious these
this i think is just at the moment a
tournament of equals the way magnus
carlsen has not shown his best chess
this year unless he
comes back to the forum that we know he
can play he starts to show that 2880
type chess then this is anybody's
tournament i think
i would have said somebody is a clear
favorite or top one this guy's going to
win i'm scared to open my mouth about
this one
usually i will have an opinion but i
don't feel like that is the case for
this tournament this is anybody's
tournament yeah speaking of adam's he
actually has had a relatively good year
he started on the low 2700s and the only
reason he's not higher is that he had a
really bad shanky tournament in
azerbaijan right and the reason well
partially is that he was invited very
last minute he was indeed he was invited
because he was replacing i think rajabov
who got sick timor yeah yeah and well
it's difficult to go into such a strong
tournament without any prior preparation
which is basically what he did a lot of
2700s will not take that risk because
exactly it's like a fighter getting
scratched on the eve of the bout and
suddenly you're asked to replace uh the
fighter
and i remember that oh pardon me we've
got uh
malcolm
just saying the final last words
[Applause]
playing wise against levon from the
united states
a man now famous in the chess world for
his winning streaks
winning all these games in a row i think
in seven it's called doing carijuana
winning five in a row it's sort of doing
a mini carijuana please welcome fabiano
[Applause]
with some relief that i asked you to
welcome the next player because we were
a little worried that he wasn't going to
get his visa but it seems like the
british embassy in moscow works a little
bit better than it used to
particularly if you've purchased the
premium service and alex
we managed to get him here on time
please welcome alexander
[Applause]
and alex is playing a popular figure
here at the classic we love this style
of play we're delighted that he's now
won a classic
please welcome to the united states
nakamura
and today's game center stage the wild
card entry the uk number one
always delights with his chess here in
london please welcome michael adams
[Applause]
and we've been playing another player
who we welcome to every single lunch of
london chess classic
um he and i are currently having a
private battle over who can eat the most
of the hair and tortoise over the road
it's one of the best that's the only
reason i've got the classic here because
uh please welcome former world champion
from india vishyanam
and as is tradition of the classic
chess in schools and communities of
course was the uh
was the driving force behind the
creation of the classic and so we always
like to have a junior player make the
first move
so i'd like you all to welcome from
watford just north of london
jeff tommy jeff come up
so
i understand that you're a very strong
player playing in the under 1800
tournament
so you know how to move
what do you normally play for your first
move
you usually play d4 okay well if you'd
like to make that move for this and
we'll see if he likes it
very good you wanna do it again just for
the for the photographers put your hand
on them
make it again replay it again that's it
everyone got that
great thanks a lot
well done thanks very much
[Applause]
well it's time to start the chess so
i'll hand you over
to my favorite chief architect
of the time um
very good
clever
all right well the last uh
tournament we had magnus carlson
unfortunately wasn't present for this
and this is why he didn't know the time
control they're being just reminded but
the players usually they just ignore it
and they're focusing since they know
very well what they're getting into
a lot of interesting chess i'm really
curious about some of these openings and
it seems like we have round one
underway
and vessel and topolof i just saw looked
like he played uh
d4 and indeed he is open against
anushkiri 1v4 right and we're going to
see if anish plays one of his very solid
openings he's known to be
not a very crazy player sticks with his
repertoire usually
yeah and his repertoire for many years
has included the grunfeld defense does
seem like we're heading that way and it
does look like he's but he's also mixed
it up a little bit he's he's quite cagey
and again we mentioned at the opening of
the show
how
anish is undefeated it's just a
remarkably
solid performance from
is is he the youngest i believe he's the
youngest editor in the inventory yeah so
you know you don't expect this type of
solidity from somebody
uh this young but
and they have uh
it's gonna be a fiance type of
groomfield extremely solid not just a
little bit solid extremely solid yeah
and we have a quick queen a4 right here
which is something that i've seen before
actually i prefer this myself the idea
here is that if you go bishop g7 as well
yeah
white has the possibility of capturing
on d5 and black cannot be captured
with the pawn right it's as simple as
that so it causes a little bit of
discomfort for the black pieces because
you have to recapture with the knife
isn't this fairly typical
groomfeld stuff anyway i mean you're at
least preventing the symmetrical pawn
structure with taking on d5 that's the
only reason this variation exists
so a4 right is it that dangerous i don't
know gary i know has looked at it of
course but i'm wondering if he wasn't
prepared for wasn't expecting and is
deciding which variation he wants to
employ he could take on c4 he can play
bishop g7 i believe even when the move
knight dd7 is possible yes i was about
to say knight bd7 just breaking this pin
so as you were saying
uh alejandro in case of cd5 black
katasan knight b6 first if he wished or
probably he should for that moment
matter attacking the queen and then
being able to as you say reestablish
symmetry with c takes d5 so knight bd7
but on the other hand who knows maybe
the queen could post up on a5 it looks a
little bit strange to get your queen out
so early in the game
with beginners all the time
that's about that yeah searching for
bobby fischer bring the queen don't
bring the queen out so early and let me
just uh go around the horn a quick bit
uh vichy and nand it's funny in
norway
jan ludwig hammer when he was playing
why black would play a reverse sicilian
every game every game and it was like
there was a line of players who were
taking down poor
uh uh
hammer on the white side and we have
that same reverse sicilian uh in the
game between vichy and mickey always
popular this favorite sicilian it's
always something that even though it's
not a top theoretical
challenge to black it always speaks
through it always something like oh what
do i feel like playing today oh reverse
reverses
there you go
and uh lavonna roni and trudua's style
has always played classical king pond
defenses to one
e4 against fabiana cariwana
he's done the same they had a game like
this in the sinkfield cup where i
remember there was that move rook b1 and
a variation very soon i remember a very
mysterious yeah and it worked out like a
charm
and
one of the things that's really amazing
about lavon when he's black
is he plays e4 e5 defenses but he really
he's really dangerous with black as
magnus carlson himself discovered in the
uh reykjavik
team championships uh that uh magnus
lost and maurice uh any insights for
today's openings
well just mentioning this particular
position that you talked about yes from
remember last year in the sing field cup
this is exactly the same position that
they battled the caruana in his 7-0
streak was able to defeat aronian in
their individual matchup precisely in
this opening had a wonderful game played
like a genius we thought he didn't have
much coming out the opening but he
showed his style and class in this exact
position he did trade on e6 was how he
played last year and he again he
dominated him in that game did carolina
but that's the last time he's defeated
aronian they've drawn several times
aronian got him back and blitz in norway
then defeated him in their one-to-one
matchup in norway and then defeated him
again here in the sink field cup
exacting revenge for last year's loss so
this matchup certainly an important one
right out the gate you know that caruana
is having memories of defeating him the
last time will he be able to finally get
back at him and win today's game
and it seems like we already have a
different move here in the carana
aronian game as i see
that karana has moved d4
definitely and just as maurice was
pointing out i think that that that game
uh
it went like bishop takes c6 and wasn't
there like a
b4 at some point and then there was
something like a rook b1
something like it was something like
this at some point yeah yeah it was
really uh
trench warfare
but somehow white ended up emerging with
the kingside initiative just out of the
blue he managed to win a very nice game
even though we didn't quite understand
right exactly
it was something very very special let's
continue just to look around
uh a mainline zveznikov that looks like
magnus carlsen playing black don't think
i've ever seen rangos play as fashion
cove
well let's just say you got me stumped
myself i can't just like throw it out
there magnus plays a lot of stuff it's
very hard
but certainly this fashion of cough
hasn't been and i love the contrast of
the features repertoire aronian is the
type of player that knows his very solid
repertoire extremely deeply and only
plays that i mean you cannot pay aronian
to play e4 c5 he will not do it exactly
but magnus seems to not know everything
as deeply as for example azeronian and
sometimes he gets punished like in the
team championship he was out prepared
with white and lost
but sometimes he's able to play whatever
and surprise his opponents for example
now playing especially sicilian which is
a very solid opening
it's now become a very solid opening it
used to be a very crazy sharp resilient
but nowadays it's transformed itself
into a rather dull solid opening mainly
because of the efforts of uh
galfed in showing some very kind of uh
quiet variations
but where white can press so i can press
a little bit but it's nothing special we
have one of those type of positions
where white takes on f6 before uh
after playing knight t5 instead of p4
yeah which is a very big difference yeah
allowing black to take back with the
bishop he has established this knight on
d5 it's never going to go away but on
the other hand black has the pair of
bishops and
he's basically saying that the knight on
d5 is cool but it's not enough to bring
you an advantage exactly and uh
oftentimes this bishop somehow slips to
g5 right where it's like active
and this knight on d5 just looks very
pretty
but uh
oftentimes it also acts as a block hater
against the d6 spot yeah so uh but this
all of these moves are very well known
in fact rugby is definitely not the main
one
g5 is the main line but rook created
something that seemed very often i mean
it's also almost as common and going
into more opening theories let's go with
maurice ashley who has updates in one of
the games
well just to update this game i stand
corrected fabiano caron actually
defeated levon ironian in the grenke
chess classic this year so that has been
his last victory but then he got
defeated twice remember
there was a time when aronian was by far
and away the number two challenger i
mean the number two player in the world
the one that everybody thought you know
that could be a great matchup carlson
versus aronian in a world championship
everybody wanted to see aronian very
smooth very solid a great player
genius player in fact some of his games
are just absolutely brilliant and then
it was really last year when that was
usurped by fabiano carwana when
everybody was saying it's fabi who we
want to see play against carlson since
then it's been topsy turvy and now no
one really knows that will be decided at
the candidates tournament in march now
we should say when nakamura was here in
saint louis uh the last time when he
played against caruana in the in the
match that they had here the the
showdown in st louis
naca said he's not sure that you're
going to see a lot of theory being
played here in london he was going to be
careful himself to reveal too much
because he had his eye on the candidates
tournament in march
though when fabi came down he said uh-uh
i'm not thinking about march right now i
want to focus on my next tournament i
got my eyes on the london chess classic
as a big event so we'll see how much
theory gets played keep ir to see how
many
mainline openings are played at this
tournament as the players definitely all
want to be the one to play against
magnus carlsen in next year's world
championship
and speaking of mainline theory uh let's
go take a look at the last game we
haven't actually seen yet this hikaru
nakamura game that he's black against
alexander griszchuk and i have to say
one of the biggest disappointments i've
seen in an opening being incorporated to
a player
was uh hikaru nakamura chosen to add the
berlin defense to his repertoire i
always felt that he was a very fun very
exciting very
topsy topsy-turvy player with the black
pieces he loved playing his sharp lines
and suddenly he was starting to play the
berlin which i never thought really
suited him i've never thought of him as
a particularly good
berlin player the way that i think
karana is a very good berlin player even
sometimes carlson
but he's shown some decent success with
it in some events i don't recall any
particularly good victories by him with
black which
i think is a key factor of being a good
berlin player that once in a while you
strike against your opponent
but he's held his own he's held a lot of
draws i know that he suffered a lot of
defeats and he's very very close to
losing a couple of other games i
particularly remember him against
caruana
but here he is and i think that because
of his opponent who his opponent is this
is a better decision than usual because
alexander christchurch is also a very
dynamic very aggressive player who i
don't also consider to be a particularly
good
berlin type of positional practitioner
yeah certainly from the black side i
know that grishock has won some really
nice victories i remember in particular
a game he absolutely crushed sergey
karyakin
in a tata steel
chess festival that was
sergey had missed time to c5
and
alexander grisha could establish tonight
on d5 and absolutely won a scorcher i
also recall just from what you were
saying there a just marvelous u.s
championship
where hikaru nakamura black against
godakamsky in a near must-win game
got to play a part it was a mainline
night or
hikaru played just a beautiful game i
mean belongs in the sicilian hall of
fame
and won and then went on to win the u.s
championship as well
yeah picking up the
berlin
it's true it doesn't seem to suit
and let's see uh the
g4 i mean
this must be regarded i guess as the
latest and greatest
in principle of course
white has this king side
majority uh e5 f2 g2 h3 and he wants to
use it
a lot of players with white pieces shy
away from this early g4 because they're
very fearful that black's counter play
with h5
an early thrust g4 could get mistimed
nonetheless grisha very very
accomplished player
had played this move g4
knight came to d4 and now we see this
move king h2 why
well h7 h5 is on black's agenda
and this move king h2
uh white readies
after h5 the move king g3 looks a little
bit strange but on the other hand by
supporting them the pawn on g4 white is
hoping that it'll get in a very quick f4
and f5
here things can get a little bit strange
but a normal a common idea for black is
actually to play knight d5
and i remember a game i think it was
actually between mickey
and vichy
where you got a kind of a structure like
this that actually it turned out that
uh white had some chances and wasn't it
elianov who
actually had a loss
he lost recently in uh berlin
with black it was from the european team
championships i believe he's actually
against christchurch
he wasn't sure it was against somebody
but i'm having trouble remembering
remembering who it was that's right i
know that bruce chuck beat somebody in
the berlin but i'm having trouble if he
was against france against ukraine it
was one of the two matches he either
beat eliana for backroad but i cannot
remember which one was which my memory
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we see so
many games these days there's been a
golden era for chess because there's
been so many great events uh this the
inaugural inaugural
uh grand chess tour i mean just look at
what that's accomplished bringing the
top players
uh together three events
in a row that's fantastic no we've had
absolutely great events and actually the
players had something to say about what
they thought the tournament was after
two well the grand chester was after two
tournaments
we have a little feature with them
it's been a lot of fun playing the grand
chess tour so far uh
it's been two of my favorite tournaments
in norway chess and also the syncful cup
um my experience competing in the grand
chess tour has been pretty good so far
i've uh i'm very close to winning both
events and i've had stable results
certainly going to the third event i
have a good chance to potentially win
the whole thing overall i haven't won
any of the two tournaments
so this might be my my chance i was not
happy with my play or my results and i
had a tough start
but hopefully i can recover in this
final leg i had a much better result in
norway than saint louis but
i hope to do well here
well it's been very interesting to watch
the tournaments from home and it's great
to take part in it well so far it
couldn't have been better of course
i'm still a leader but
this is like the final tournament and
for sure it will be very tough i'm
pretty much sure that the winner here
will be also the overall winner of
granchester
well so far i've had quite a lot of fun
i mean it's always great to play against
these guys and i hope to
show you even better results i don't
think
anyone has a guarantee to to be a
favorite in this kind of event so far
for most of the players
everything is still open and i believe
the person who wins this tournament most
likely to be the overall winner anyway
it's really going to come down to who
finishes i think and first and second
place my results haven't been too good
so i'm hoping to
redeem myself here in a moment
it's interesting the way the players
refer to it they never say this
particular player is leading until right
like wow it's completely over right the
way for example karana was leading in
the sink field cup a couple years ago
but nowadays they're like okay whoever
wins this one is they'll take it the
odds on you know and just in that
feature first of all i thought uh
hikaru looked particularly jet lagged
but i was somehow i was forcefully
reminded of the the game in the sink
fill cup where basically on the
the last move of time control
essentially car ijuana blundered
absolutely against
world champion magnus carlson and magnus
who had been in bad shape that whole
game turned to tables and how meaningful
how truly meaningful it was for the
standings and i i'm just thinking that
in this event we're gonna have a hundred
thousand dollar swings come the final
round you know as the players jockey for
position in the uh in the tour well the
tournament is definitely wide open and i
think that the fact that magnus carlson
is the striking position but not in one
of the top three will make it even more
interesting yeah and we have maurice
ashley with more analysis from the
opening
well i don't know why i'm so fascinated
by this particular match up but it's
getting more and more weird you know
back in the 18th century the great
french play andre philadore said le
pionson lam de check which means the
pawns are the soul of chess and even
today the pawns still hold primacy in
when you're looking at pawn structures
when you're looking at how to play the
game and this one
you know i looked at it and i said why
does this remind me of a schwesnikov
like you look at it right immediately if
after bishop e3 he could have played the
move c6 aronian and after it takes takes
well look at his pawn formation it looks
oddly and you look at the pawn formation
like the game between vacilla grav and
magnus carlson it's the exact same pawn
formation but with some differences of
course the light square bishop is still
on the board and the extra night for
white if we go back to this position
again uh the position i'm showing you
after the move c6
which my engine is not letting me do i
see because it's a blight's move so i
have to bishop to e3 c6 and takes takes
it's the exact same pawn distribution on
this board as well that could have
happened in this game of course the rook
on a2 is somewhat weird but again the
ideas of putting a pawn onto a4 as would
happen in especially could happen the
control of the d5 square
again no dark no light squared bishop
though for
black very important because in the
fresno cup black usually has this light
squared bishop and that is a big part of
what keeps him in the game is to be is
to have this piece which is a very
strong piece for him
however
aronian decided you know what it's not
really a schwesnikov i'm going to play
this move queen to c8 talk about a weird
looking move stepping one square to the
right this queen is he preparing c6 is
he preparing to go to g4 and some
demonstration on the king side not clear
but again that
interweaving of pawns and strategies and
openings players all know you cannot
just study one opening you want to be
able to incorporate ideas from many
different openings so that you can be
able to play the specific opening you're
playing and know when a pattern is good
or if it's not and steer clear of bad
positions guys thank you maurice and
this also
it really is from the same um
rui lopez opening and it's always useful
for chess players to not only know one
opening but at the top they know all
openings because the pawn structure
changes into each other so often a lot
of times i tell players that it's not so
important for you to know specific moves
of theory but the understanding of why
you're playing certain moves and in the
pawn structures you understand why
you're putting your pawns in certain
squares why you're weakening certain
squares so for example this break that
maurice plays with c6 you know it comes
to him as natural as breathing right but
you have to understand why are you
weakening your d6 square why are you
giving up the d5 square and it's
something that you know it takes some
practice knowing that in this fashion
cup then they're real lopez there's
things that you can do and hopefully we
get a little bit of insight into the
chess players as they will be having
access to the confessional booth oh yes
our innovation our innovation there in
london and
well hopefully they use it sometimes
soon uh the openings are just about
getting done in london so we'll probably
gonna be expecting them sometime in the
middle game exactly i just wanted to say
one of the books that made a strong
impression as i was growing up was
reuben finds
ideas behind the chess openings so
exactly what you're talking about
instead of just simply memorizing the
latest wrinkle and let's say the
sicilian dragon you would understand the
plans and strategies and when i was
looking at this game
of uh lavone aronian and cariwan i was
forcibly reminded of this opening that i
had studied as a kid
okay this is the um
the classical rui lopez if you will
we're just going to go
uh into what was then considered the
main line d6
c3
and castles
so when i was a kid one of the things i
always ask myself
why the heck does everybody play h3 i
mean what is that a move are you really
afraid
of this move bishop g4 and there was a
time that the most fashionable move for
white
just a second let me get my mouse
was d4 just going for the center
then black would play bishop to g4
bishop
d5 pardon me
d5
knight a5 bishop c2 and as you start to
think make a comparison between
karuwana's position
and lavone aronian's
position
they thought that the and the theory
then and the theory today has
established that black absolutely it's
absolutely essential
to play this move c
7 c 6 in order to get counter play if we
go to the game at hand
sorry to the position at hand and we see
this move queen c8 that prepares the c7
c6 and
i like
this move very much let's say white
plays a move like rook a2
now after c6
takes i really like the idea of
recapturing the queen
rather than recapturing of the night
then it feels to me like a very
uh close to a night or sicilian where
you're nice
your knight actually is nicely placed on
d7 a little bit more flexible can go to
c5 can go to b6
and somehow i feel that
once again
lavone with his deep knowledge and
understanding
has
outprepared his opponent this looks like
a perfectly lit
reasonable position for black and
interestingly in the other variation you
were mentioning earlier after the c6
break white does take on c6 you actually
don't take back with the knight you
develop your queen and then take the
doomed opponents on c6 that's right
right with the queen yeah it's a nice
little nuance there isn't yeah so this
idea of knowing the strategies of one
particular line can sometimes
morph into a
different opening but you get the same
ideas and this is a nice one i like what
lavone is doing and we do see fabiana
carrana deep in thought after this move
so it seems like he's out of preparation
in a position that well it doesn't seem
like it's
the latest and greatest in theory but it
does seem like the pawn structure is
going to be something that is a little
bit of annoying for fabiano right now to
figure out i actually was thinking about
this position on my own i'm not really
sure what to play here for white right
it's sort of like you want to somehow
take advantage of the fact that maybe
this pawn is
you know standing out here on b5 a move
like a4 would be highly desirous except
it just loses upon after b4 and the
knight the pawn on e4 gets captured
uh just a second and if we do
some preparatory move like knight d2 in
order to get in a4 well black is simply
too fast right it seems like 92 let's go
of the center for no particular reason
exactly also i have to worry about
knight g4 my bishop on e3 is trapped
yeah so that's not really working
the other thing is well this bishop on
e3 may look good but it doesn't do
anything in particular
maybe something to be said for bishop g5
right away the idea is that if you play
c6
i could do
what they do in the zveznikov and try to
go for a quick
uh occupation of the square d5 now here
one one thing
i noticed that with the rook on a2 how
silly that looks alejandro isn't that
you don't see that kind of tactic very
often like that you know you go queen c4
hitting the pawn on e4 as well as the
fun on a2 that's a bizarre one uh
um you won't see that in european
manuals
an interesting position i think still
full of possibilities i like this bishop
g5 move as a preparatory idea but of
course the problem with it would be that
well black's probably not going to play
c6 immediately just other options right
including
bd7 it's like uh black is in a hurry on
the one hand to play c7 c6 that he can
do it on his time
i mean he's not the one that has to uh
you press matters whereas white suddenly
is positions a little rigid not so
flexible and uh well again i think lavon
will be very satisfied with the outcome
of this particular opening i definitely
agree maurice has more insights on the
opening
again we're talking pawn structure and
you know there you go over games you
made this big point alejandro it's you
you said they study all the openings i'm
sure a lot of students out there went oh
my god really i got to study all the
openings no that's let's just clarify
that point it's not about studying the
openings intimately it's about knowing
the structures and general directions of
all the openings not just saying i only
study this
tunnel vision opening but that you go
over so many games in your life just
studying grand master games the games of
the great players that you realize that
in that structure this is what they like
to do and even though you don't study
the nuances the fine points of move
orders you do know the general direction
and the kind of important things that
happen in that kind of structure so when
you go back to your pet opening you can
say oh yeah that reminds me of something
else that i've seen and something that
happened to me just now it flicked off a
memory take a look at this game between
vasil and topolov and anish geary in the
grunfeld and in this position geary
played the move e5 bursting out with
this move e5
looks a bit unusual the bishop is now
and and knight and queen are happy
they're training their sights on this
square certainly this d-pawn may not be
happy to have seen the move e5 appear on
the board
but this bishop is quite happy along
this long diagonal and that is a point a
very aggressive move not typical from
the youngstagiri we know he's very solid
he doesn't try to do too much with the
black pieces as he hasn't lost a game in
the entire tour but e5 certainly hyper
aggressive and when i saw it i said
remind me of something else so i had to
go look it up and indeed i was correct
it was in this moment that bobby fischer
against byrne one of the burn brothers i
think was robert byrne he was playing
against and in this position a very
famous game where right now fisher
himself played
e5 and take a look at the differences
because there's a knight on b6 in the
game with with geary and his bishop is
still back home on c8 fischer had gotten
these two moves in to play this move e5
one of the most spectacular games in
chess history a great win by fischer if
you haven't seen it then you have to see
it this is the necessity of having a
great chess culture of reading the
classics of making sure you know all the
great games because you never know this
game was played in 1963
and we fast forward ahead
52 years and again we see the move e5 of
course the difference being
quite real knight on b6 instead and
bishop on c8 we'll see if that and
nuance makes a difference in this
particular pawn structure and we're
going to give you a chance to actually
go over that game if you want to look it
up in your database or online as we take
a very short commercial break as we're
finishing the openings in the london
chess classic round one we'll be right
back
[Music]
i'm mike matheny manager of the
cardinals in chess fanatic many people
don't know that st louis has a chess
history as rich as its baseball but the
world renowned chess club and scholastic
center of st louis across from the world
chess hall of fame our goal is to teach
play and promote the sport come to the
central west end and experience all that
chess has to offer
welcome to chess.com
is social
now you can play chess with your friends
whenever you want whether that's middle
of the day
or middle of the night you can get
instantly matched up with one of over 5
million other members from around the
world
you play live games in real time turn
based games at your convenience or
tournaments with anyone at any time
chess.com is mobile
you can play online from your computer
or you can play on the go from your
tablet or your smartphone no matter
where you go whether you're at work
grabbing a bite to eat
or just enjoying some time in the park
your games are there with you and
keeping multiple chess games going has
never been easier
chess.com is for learning don't just
play chess get better the best chess
training resources have never been more
accessible learn essential chess
strategy quickly and easily with the
extremely popular tactics trainer tool
improve your game in ways you didn't
were possible with training videos by
chess masters
and regardless of where you're at now
take your game to the next level with
multiple simple to use training tools
[Music]
chess.com is for everyone
over 250 million chess games have been
played on chess.com
and it doesn't matter if you're a
beginner
or a grand master
chess.com is the place to play and learn
chess
so create your free account now see what
chess.com is for
you i'm mike matheny and there's nothing
better than watching some of the best
players compete at the highest level st
louis has a long tradition of great
players and championship moments
beginning august 23rd st louis will
witness another great sporting event as
the 2015 sink field cup plays host to
the 10 top chess players in the world
you can watch in person at the chess
club and scholastic center of st louis
or watch online at
grandchesttour.com you won't want to
miss a moment of this historic
tournament
[Music]
we're live here from london so we are
underway on round one
of the london chess classic and we have
some interesting openings a lot of
solid defenses from black hat team so
we're going to have to see how the white
players decide to crack it down we're
analyzing right on the break they get
between fabiano caruana and levon
aronian and even though it doesn't seem
like the most exciting game yet right
it's something very interesting because
we're always interested in this pawn
structure that's ever-changing and
ever-present especially the reload pest
type of pawn structures that this little
nuances really make a big difference and
it seems like fabiano caron is still
kind of thinking about how to crack open
black's position which looks ultra ultra
solid exactly let me just say before i
jump into that game i was challenged
channeling my inner maurice ashley
because uh maurice when he saw that move
of onish gary against vessel and topolof
the game that i got up on my screen
i immediately flashed
robert byrne bobby fisher and i said my
god that was a great game but it wasn't
just the game
that made the impression on me it was
the story behind the game
and the story was that as bobby was
making all of the sacrifices there was
live grand master commentary during that
u.s championship
and the grand master commentary
team was saying
bobby was lost
bobby had a lost position
robert byrne he comes into the
commentary hall he said what are you
doing here he says well the game's over
they said did you win
robert looked at them very strangely he
said no i resigned
and as a kid i just found that
fascinating that that top grand masters
didn't understand uh bobby's play
now of course the idea behind the move
by anish gary as maurice was saying
is anish is not sitting back waiting for
white to pile up on this pawn on d5
rather he's trying to get in his break
and after something like for example
takes
we either knight takes but i'm thinking
bishop takes and what anish is thinking
is like okay i can get in this
d5 d4 there's going to be a whole lot of
trades
and the game's going to end up being a
draw also there's even bishop g4 for
black so it's a very active defense now
coming back to to the game that you're
talking about there that was the lavon
aronian game right let me just bring
that up on my screen really point out
the difference between
chess players let's say in the olden age
and now because a lot of players always
like to compare you know who would win
between fisher absolutely i play those
games all the time with everybody i can
but it sometimes to me it doesn't make
any sense because you mentioned some of
the top grand masters back then
criticizing the move e5 right and as i
sit here i already have all this
knowledge that you know happened years
before i was born
and i'm like yeah of course you go e5
like
that's the whole point of the position
right and to me it's interesting that in
the in there was a point in history
where e5 was considered to be dubious
and like not the move not only dubious
just blunderful yeah and to me it was
like well i mean what else are you
supposed to do of course you go e5 well
and the reason for that was because of
the technical prowess of anatoly karpov
and in his heyday i mean a weak square a
weak pawn he would ruthlessly exploit
and the move e5
you get an isolated d5 pawn you didn't
want to play it against anatoly karpov
and so that was why
you know he kind of put a kibosh on
these liberating moves that had uh
some
static weaknesses but dynamic potential
speaking of that for example this
fashion cup sicilian which was once upon
a time considered to be just unplayable
like dumb yeah nowadays we see it at the
top of the top of the chest tournament
maurice has some explanation for us on
this particular magnus indeed it looks
like great minds think alike i was
thinking the exact same thing especially
itself was garbage i mean how can you
play like this until the the players
from chelyabinx
in in russia played just like this
especially being the leading exponent
and all of a sudden everybody said oh
this stuff is actually sound you can
play like this now the move bishop takes
night i often talk about how bishop
takes knight is the most important
exchange in all of chess
at the grand master level it's the one
move that imbalances the position in a
very specific way creating the minor
piece imbalance and whenever you play
bishop takes knight it's always
important which bishop took the knight
in this case the dark square bishop took
the knight that means that white will
have a light square light square
dominance because this bishop cannot
guard the light squares these two pieces
will cancel out but this knight can
attack light squares that this bishop
cannot so you watch the game proceed c3
castles knight c2 rook b8 and bam an
assault on the light squares because you
have a light square preponderance
however this game took a curious turn
after takes vascular grave played the
move knight c to b4 and after knight
takes c takes b4 and now the position is
very strange indeed he's still hoping
that his light square piece will
dominate that knight looks very strong
now take a look at the way the engine
plays and look at that magnus has found
the very first move engine's main line
bishop to b7 now you may wonder so
what's that bishop doing on b7 let us
just snap my pawn back i'm nice and
comfy and instantly the engine gives
bishop takes d5 as the prime move this
has been the dream of white to start
with i want to dominate the light
squares and now
complete domination of the light squares
by all of whites pieces that are
currently in the game these two are
light squares this bishop wants to get
up but the problem is black dominates on
the dark squares in this position and
it's not so easy the initiative is with
black queen to d7 first of all attacking
the rook forget the pawn you want it you
can have it now that you've won your
light squares let's talk dynamics your
king is still in the center rook coming
down this b-pawn is hanging that one
will drop as well but again let's talk
about this piece if we make a couple of
moves bishop e2 rook takes b4 looking to
win yet another pawn also with the move
rook d4 on tap and don't get funky and
try to win your pawn back because after
rooksie won check now this crazy move
queen c8 and suddenly you can't castle
because of rook to d4 thank you very
much stuff's just dropping
all of a sudden black has tremendous
dynamics now we all started back here
with magnus's first move bishop to b7
who would have thought that that one
bishop that you you think you want to
keep would now want to trade on d5 i'll
make this point as well bishop takes d5
e takes d5 the engines give a5 out of
nowhere again attacking on the dark
squares looking to get down to b2 and if
you try to calm it down e4 and this
bishop erupts so not so easy to control
the game a wild battle potentially in
this feshnikov and mvl is well aware
that there are dangers in this position
and he has taken on a4 will magnus play
this incredibly counterintuitive move
bishop takes d5
i always felt this fashion cuff was
counter-intuitive as it is it is and in
the spirit of the position if you don't
play counter-intuitive i feel like
you're just going to be worse and i
think that the knight on d5 even though
sometimes you kind of leave it there
taking on d5 right now because i am as
fashionable player looks like the thing
you have to do you just have to liberate
your pieces i remember
analyzing this feshnikov with a very uh
talented
dutch
junior player daniel stellwag
and daniel just loved the um
especially because he said it was so
easy for black black makes all of these
sacrifices to liberate his pieces and at
the end of the game you know he has all
of this dynamic play and this is like
these moves a5 and uh i wanted to toss
in something that maurice had said
uh in that uh one line as well
like uh after bishop b7 if white tries
to calm it down as moreso aptly
described it if he tries to calm it down
by playing knight c3 with the slow idea
of rook takes a4 and bishop c4 well
daniel stalwagen will be the first to
tell you just play d5 here whenever you
get a liberating break you go for it and
if you take with a pawn well this is
just instantly understood by especially
another liberating break and it's so
easy for black to play so daniel loved
the zveznikov and again it was so hard
for players like me
because you know we had been raised just
thinking it's unplayable garbage was the
actual
word used by
[Music]
maurice and indeed suddenly the garbage
becomes really playable and in the early
days by the way the early adopters of
this feshnikov won an amazingly number
of easy victories as black absolutely it
was like white players just didn't
understand what was going on it was
incredible right and it had a very
strong resurgence in the very early
2000s i remember that moshirov and lekko
as
opposite players as you can think of
right both adopted this vegetable with
very very good results and at some point
even topalov was playing it
maybe even gary right yeah
yeah gary gave it a whirl yep i mean it
was definitely the top of everybody's
list for some time and mainly out of
fashion i think it dropped by a little
bit but some people have kept it on
their permanent repertoire and i think
that the dynamic possibilities given by
all the sacrifices particularly with
fuels the ability to keep it as a
mainstream opening yeah every time you
think a mainstream defense or a
mainstream opening has gotten killed
whether it be a dragon a grunfell the
king's indian somehow it comes back into
fashion because of some
innovation some creative idea and
yesterday i want to ask you a question
in your life how many times have you
heard the dragon is dead
oh about it once every 10 years
it just goes through these i remember in
the 1970s i was playing in the u.s
junior championships with john
fedorowitz john fedorwicz loved the
dragon as black
one time he just got his head kicked in
by some wonderful you know innovation
and he dropped kick his sicilian his
favorite sicilian draft uh
uh hardback book down the stairs i'll
never play the dragon again and then you
know like magnus started taking up the
dragon before he became world champion
by the way i wanted to draw your
attention to the game between alexander
grishof
hikaru nakamura we saw this move king h2
hikaru has gone into the tank i don't
think he's i don't think he's moved in
20 minutes that's a very deep thing
actually because i remember
157 i want to say yeah christian played
king h2
and then he's just he hasn't moved and
by the standards of the berlin i just
want to say that normally speaking you
play these positions quite quickly i
mean he knows what's what in these
positions
and um it's a very subtle kind of
position because i feel that just a
little mistake by black makes this
position
quite bad right you have to be very
careful especially with the way that
white's playing so aggressively with g4
king h2 wanting to play f4 f5 right not
developing his bishop on c1 just yet i
mean it definitely gives ikaro the
impression that if he's not careful yeah
in the next couple of moves to play some
kind of inaccuracies he's going to be
facing some kind of unpleasant trees and
we've seen gristrok as we were
mentioning earlier being able to really
exploit them
in a very few very past uh months yeah
and it's it is what you say very
concrete position but if we were to take
let us say the standard berlin approach
which is to play h5
trying to create this weakness on g4
king g3 a trade
okay these pieces are quite passive so
you want to play knight d5 right
and you're gaining a tempo
again i'm not saying that this is the
best or worse move but if you trade
trade
you think
that this position somehow black would
have worked out the kinks
but it is a difficult position to really
get a firm grip on because at the at
first blush
you're you've got the two bishops and
your pawn structure has suddenly been
improved right so you think this is more
than acceptable until you remember
black's king castle it's every time i
feel like oh yeah black's doing great
it's just castle and you're done with it
right but you can't and with black's
king being so weak on your aid always
afraid of an e6 break coming precisely
it's just like what do i do with my
pieces how do i coordinate them right
and it becomes so difficult to actually
answer this in what otherwise would be a
very normal position right and that's
and that's the thing uh
white doesn't have to do anything
particularly special and you'll re
recall in stavinger in norway
that fabiona karjuana
defeated world champion magnus carlson
in a game that really okay magnus did
air
but imperceptibly
but before that error he was under great
pressure it was like the berlin had a
problem right it already had some issues
in that position exactly it wasn't just
that he blundered which he did right but
already the position was uncomfortable
exactly
and this is the thing that i think
hikaru why hikaru is going into a very
deep think
is because the normal remedies
that black would undertake
to defuse white's initiative
aren't there i mean normally you get
something like an a5 and an a4 you kind
of remind white that there is a queen
side on the board well there's nothing
going on on the queen side in this
structure and again from white's point
of view you mentioned it very
accurately when white gets in the move
f5 with black's king constantly stuck in
the center this uh
sword of damocles is just hanging over
there's always this e6
tactical potential in white's position
and it's not
easy for black to to defuse this kind of
slow initiative this building e6 is
definitely a very key uh move in the
berlin i remember the game kasparov
kramnik from astana which was the first
time that they played berlin after the
world championship
won brilliantly
with an easy sacrifice a straight-up
sacrifice and since then it's become a
staple of something that black really
has to be careful of yep and actually
gristrok won a game very recently also
with this e6 break so it's definitely
something that carl has to be
considering is that as soon as white's
able to play e6 he needs to be able to
have an appropriate response to it and
it's not always good just to capture the
pawn sometimes it has to be captured
upon and make sure your position is not
collapsing
well put
any particular favorites uh that we
haven't seen the vichy anand
game uh
well pardon me this is the magnus
carlson game rook takes a4
uh
and i just wanted to go to vichy's game
because that was
i keep gotta i keep going up okay so we
got a very standard reverse dragon kind
of position right
so
in these positions uh as white
the interesting thing for me
when i play white's position
i like
this bishop on c1 to come to the long
diagonal right i've never really been a
that big a fan of putting it on e3 i
know it's a popular decision
this in
my career the most considered the most
aggressive move was a3 followed by b4
uh vishy took an approach that i think
he took also in
in norway
uh which was to bring the bishop to e3
this slow play this rook e8 bishop f8 by
by mickey that's always been the
classical way of doing things for black
you just simply over protect this pawn
on e5 and you stick your knight on d4
and it's considered that when you play
knight to d4 any time white trades
black ends up with his rook nicely
placed on e8 putting pressure down on
this pawn on e2 it's the most standard
setup i would guess against this kind of
structure
it's actually made the bishop e3 move
more of a sideline i would say now
even though it was once considered to be
the most natural way of developing i
definitely see a3b4 more commonly i even
saw nakamura play against
recently in the millionaire chass
tournament he played a very quick rook
b1 b4 right and i thought that changed
the character of the position quite
nicely it worked out very well for hikar
with that game right um so i'm slightly
surprised i would say to see such a
quick bishop a3 because i've always felt
like black's play was so obvious you
know your bishop wouldn't fade knight on
d4 bonus c7 goes to c6 just to block up
the entire uh queen side yes you put
your pawn on c6 a very important as you
were saying yeah
uh
yes and then you put all those pawns
there and you go
so what yeah
right exactly
so again uh not too much in it at this
moment for vishy
i just want to say we haven't spoken
about this you because
after his brilliant start in norway
where he was undefeated he was cruising
took uh
second he came out with the stinker of a
tournament here in saint louis and i
know he was really looking forward to
his visit to saint louis he enjoyed his
time here very very much it's just that
his result
didn't match his own his own enthusiasm
for this event
um
he needs to put it together yeah and
every time you you count vichy out like
in the candidates you know like the guy
can put together back in a brilliant
brilliant result so having said all of
this
if i was in white shoes i would ask
myself well what can i do
to
mix things up make
black's life a little bit difficult well
the whole point of putting the knight on
e4
is to put it on c5 okay
so now we've got ideas that combined
with this bishop on g2 this knight on c5
were eyeballing this pawn on b7
it comes back to
your point
that you are making
it really feels like white needs a b4
something to really put some pressure on
in this case however black is
beautifully
equipped to meet the move b4 with a5
if you play a3 so at first blush you
think white's doing really good he's got
this knight on c5 until you see this
move rook a2
and you go hey wait a minute
that was an uninvited guest you know
like where did that rook
suddenly that rook on a8 that was
bothering nobody suddenly puts pressure
on e2 there are two players there are
two players right this is not play on
one goal so uh all to play for all three
results possible with mickey adams the
wild card player in this london classic
maurice
well certainly a big development in the
game between carlson
and mvl this position we were talking
about that move bishop takes knight the
most important trade in all of chess it
changes the position dynamically the
engines we're giving bishop takes on d5
as a very important move here giving
black the edge i kept analyzing and all
the lines seem to be good for black
maybe white can maintain equality that
is drawing chances by giving away these
two pawns and allowing black to keep
this one in some end game and get some
chances just get castled get out of the
middle as fast as possible but it was
always black
instead carlson did a deep think and
played instead another move queen to c8
in this position queen to c8 a typical
sreshnikov id i know yasser's thinking
what are you doing to your position guy
i mean did you have to just wreck your
king position like this well the engines
are giving knight takes on f6 as the
best move g takes f6 and then bishop to
d3 and when you see two moves like this
happen you think this guy can't play
chess what is he doing these kinds of
moves however now the engine gives the
the amazingly uh well typical in this
line but
very nice tactically takes on d5 after
d5 and now rook to d8 and
i know everybody's going wait wait wait
you're king is there a mate do i kill
you if i play queen h5 for example look
how black is getting tremendous counter
play already the engines do say that
castles is the best move here you don't
have to play queen h5 which looks quite
attractive in this position but of
course you've got to think about a nice
little queen c1 check that might happen
on the board so that doesn't work but
castles is possible and after that rook
takes on d5 and although black's king
for kingside confirmation looks porous
there's nothing wrong with this position
black white doesn't have enough
initiative his rook is wayward on this
side black's just fine here queen c8 an
equalizing move and it looks as though
he missed what looks counter-intuitive
sometimes you might call it natural
though that very important trade in
chess bishop takes night
guys wow thank you maurice one uh line
maurice that you didn't mention
that again i if i was in magnus's pardon
me in mvl shoes i want to say
i would have
wanted to defuse that
that was the bishop takes d5
the queen takes d5 and what was our
follow-up move after queen takes d5 was
it rooks
queen d7 yes that's right i wanted to
play the move b2 b3 so on on a very good
day
all i really want to do is just put my
bishop on c4 and just try to
do my best to sit on the position you
know right
again defusing uh black's early
initiative because if i can get
you know a grip you know on the position
it looks pretty pleasant right so
maurice if i can come to you and ask
what the engine's response to b3 might
be i was i'm curious
yeah we humans think alike it's exactly
the move i thought because i said why am
i going to take the pawn give you all
that play forget that how do i stabilize
the position b3 was the response except
the engines came back screaming with the
move queen to g4
queen g4 out and i said
what are you doing over there there's
nothing happening and when you start to
look at it you realize now i can't move
my bishop and anything you do on this
side be very careful an f3 move you
might see a move like bishop h4 check he
said well i didn't i thought i was
controlling the position but all of a
sudden
i'm losing weight i can't do that and
then three is not possible you can also
play h3 in this position except he drops
back still stops you from taking because
your pawn's under attack and now he's
starting to look on your dart squares
and suddenly it's black completely for
choice in this position don't forget
this rook might show up and end up on c1
you're not happy here at all so it's
just not enough time black is perfectly
fine pawn schmons you can have a6 d6 in
fact they're in my way they're
irrelevant get rid of them black has
full play and the whole only thing that
matters right now is this king on e1 so
that was a great opportunity there that
magnus missed this would have been
perfect dynamic play for him queen d7
bishop takes
again looks counterintuitive but bishop
takes and queen d7 will spot on for him
with great play this position however
looks like it's just going to be settled
in one of those potentially quiet draws
wow i totally underestimated the effect
of queen g4 i mean
wondering can't you play rook fc8
instead of queen g4 also because i think
that movie
looked very strong you cannot go bishop
c4 i thought that was a really nice why
can't i go bishop c4 sorry uh that
import i see what you oh that's a beauty
yeah let's share that with our viewers
so bishop c4 looks great after castles
it's nearly game over right it seems
very nice for white but you just can't
play it
rook takes c4 i can't recapture the
bishop with the pawn because i'm hanging
this rook if i recapture with the queen
i've got a back rank issue right a very
nice uh variation indeed and just to
finish it off
there's no back rank checkmate for white
so i got bishop's still covering exactly
oh no i've got uh bishop dropping back
to d8
and suddenly
likes a piece up it's over so it would
have been a very interesting set of
variations yeah we're going to leave you
with that as carlson's step like queen
ca it's a very dynamic move also because
i think it is enticing the move knight
takes f6 which would be
quite interesting pawn structure wrecked
for black but with a lot of activity and
we're going to have to see how mvl
reacts we're going to take a break and
we'll be right back with the games from
the london chess classic
[Music]
so
welcome back here we are in the first
round of the london chess classic the
players hard at work we were just done
with the opening phase of today's round
and we're definitely getting there into
the
section where players are thinking about
how to break through their opponent's
defenses exactly how to react with the
pressure that i think white is
generating in most boards except maybe
for the carlson position which i like it
a little bit for carlson the more i see
it indeed
well i wanted to put you both my
colleagues maurice and alejandro on the
spot
because as long as i've been playing
chess
you know the formula has always been
hold with black
press with white
i'm not seeing the pressing okay with
the exception of maybe the alexander
grisha scheme i'm thinking black
in the world's elite is more than
holding his own at least as far as the
opening
uh in this first round goes
what's go what gives what's happening
with these elite players how come
they're not
pressing with white or do you think
uh i've overstated it i think it's
become more difficult i think that
uh with the advance of computer chess
you know a lot of people think that
computer chess advanced all chess but
it's actually not so true computers have
made it much better
defending than they are at attacking and
this might sound strange because they
see all the tactics but it's actually
made a lot of variations viable which
previously were thought to be unplayable
things that require very precise defense
are suddenly supposed to be like well if
you can just get out of it why not so a
lot of sharp variations which were
supposed to be lost
or very difficult to play for black
suddenly are just mainstream unaccepted
because well the computer just gave you
the entire variation all you have to do
is memorize it and i think white has
been shying away from a lot of
variations which the sharpest line the
sharpest lines for example things like
the poison pond which wow still is
played quite often uh it's not as played
as it was for example like in the late
80s because it's been found out that a
ton of those variations which were cool
and exciting the computer is just like
oh you go here here here and it's a
force perpetual
so i think that of course black's uh
holding and why it's pressing but the
way that white has to press us to be
more creative it's not as
straightforward as here i'm going to
play something sharp and
we're going to blow it yeah and we're
going to go into some tactical
variations it's going to be very
difficult for you to do anything and
that's going to be the game nowadays i
think that black's much better prepared
the defensive resources are much
stronger and it's forced wide into
trying to create more positional
approaches in which the pressing exists
but it's not as clear-cut as it was
before
yeah and i'm thinking of those great old
days again of the 80s and 90s where
somebody brought you know the bazooka
novelty that just blew away
a mainline variation and you know you
just thought okay the main line is
unplayable and what you're saying is
that the main lines that you had
considered unplayable there's actually a
sharp resource defensive resource in the
computer
in the position that the computer has
found right and suddenly people are
adopting that looking at the game of uh
alexander grishock
and
u.s champion hikaru nakamura we were
actually saying that the position after
knight d5 we found very favorable for
white
so hikaru came up with the move c6 c5
attacking this knight in the center
knight came to b5 with a very
straightforward idea of i'm going to
fork your king and queen
and then
king d8 so we've seen the king coming
back and forth
which crazily enough is very common in
the berlin once upon a time this would
have considered you know like
yeah people would have been shaking
their heads like you're cruising for a
bruising and now you know if you if you
go with a straightforward f4
this knight might end up you know
uh one day on this a3 square far from
the action a little
yeah but let's see how it would go
because again this is like a really
sharp um
way of uh for white to play it right
where do you see uh alejandro in this
position after the move f4 again it's
very straightforward white is wants to
play f5 and bring this bishop out from
c1 to a more aggressive square whether
it be g5 or f4 where do you see black
you know this is one of those positions
that's always baffling me i'm not a very
good berlin player okay
you know i will go to the conventional
booth
i look at the position i'm like i want
to go g5 and break your pawn structure
create some dynamics and i'm like okay
g5 is just a stupid movie okay you know
from white's much better okay so my
initial instincts are all wrong right
and i want to think that somehow black
starts consolidating he plays either a6
or knight c6 plays it slow you kind of
kick the guy back yeah knight c6
and maybe goes to d4 so this pawn on e5
i can't get in
right away
so i have to do something like
in 94 and if it comes a little slower
okay h6 or something to just
delay this uh right what you said this
break g5 breaking up the team h6 a
little bit slow for my taste but okay i
get it
bishop me come out to e3 i got a tempo
yeah you'll have to probably play a b6
i'll bring my rook and it already looks
pleasant for white but at the end of the
day you still got this night stranded
don't you you got your night stranded
and if you don't actually create the f5
move at some point then it's like
well what are you going to do in the
position so a lot of the times
if
you know
white develops maximally he cannot
improve the position anymore right very
common in the berlin yes then it's like
well so what wow remember the world
championship match game magnus carlson
is white vicious
magnus looked like he had everything
knight on e4 knight on knight d5 knight
f6 yeah and he maximized everything and
then suddenly came b5 and vishy took
over the initiative he lost a
spectacular spectacular game and one of
the best moves in the match and one of
the best moves i've seen is b5
wow yeah i mean i actually wanted vichy
to win that one yeah it was such a cool
movie it was so visual i i get it that
was a great game and so the berlin is a
very hard animal to understand it's very
tricky it definitely changes the
character the position not playing with
queens makes it very very different from
normal openings the fact that the
structure is so unusual the fact that
black has the pair of bishops so the
fight that white actually wants to break
open the position because he has more
development is counter-intuitive to the
fact that the opponent has the pair of
bishops so you don't want to open the
position right it becomes a very strange
balance of things yeah and we're going
to have to see how they handle the
structure which is so so weird yeah
uh speaking of magnus's game by the way
um
pardon me mvl has gone into a deep think
after this move queen c8 he has not
just took an f6 actually finally okay
maurice's uh
first move was to take on f6 bishop d3
and i think we saw this move hd5
yeah takes rook d8 this was the line
that maurice was pointing out which is a
very typical sveshnikov idea and
actually instead of uh rook d8 i was
thinking of the move e4 which is also a
very typical rice fashion cuff kind of
garbage yeah
you just throw the pawns forward and the
idea is that okay white has a white
square bishop so you're trying to
isolate it away from the game you cannot
take on e four i hope because you can
play rook e8 and pin the bishop oops
it's a very
interesting move though i can imagine
that if you can get away without playing
e4 because it might allow f3 at some
point right magnus might not want to
play it but it's always a resource that
he can consider maurice
very exciting middle games uh brewing
what have you got for us
well you have it right and something
really interesting transpiring on the
game in the game between topalov and
anish geary remember we pointed this
bobby point out this bobby fischer
position you told that excellent story
as let's just go down the trail a little
bit d d takes e5 knight takes e5 rook to
d1 was burns choice and now the move
knight d3 this rook leaving the f2
square the knight suddenly appears on d3
and after queen c2 thinking everything
was hunky dora he was going to take this
knight suddenly the sacrifice knight
takes on f2 beautiful explosion in the
position after king takes very
importantly this move knight to g4 check
and after king g1 knight takes e3 a nice
little fork you say well after queen d2
is he going to take the rook
uh-uh he took the bishop on g2
beautiful decision and after king takes
suddenly d4 and black's pieces have just
exploded this bishop is fantastic and
note the bishop on a6 attacking this
knight as well so you cannot move the
knight from c3 away after knight takes
on d4 the bishop got back to b7 on the
long diagonal and then after the king
move had to move to f1 because of
tactics this move queen d7 and fischer
calculated everything the queen coming
to h3 and all kinds of beautiful
finishes because this piece is attacking
uh he's going to deal with the g2 square
too much to bear with all the pressure
on his position this is where he
resigned when all the gm said what are
you doing but if you put this position
into your engine you'll find out there
is no defense black is winning beautiful
line note by the way i want to go back
to this moment the bishop was on e on a6
right here and a knight appeared on d3
right okay
that's not possible in the geary game
you say bishop can't get to a6 how's the
knight going to get to d3 well let's
fall forward a couple of moves knight
takes h3 to stop anything from going to
g4 remember the sacrifice that happened
here
bishop to f5
knight d4
and suddenly bishop into d3 itself now
this rook has moved to e1 of course the
threat is f4 so what is the engine
saying is the best move
bishop back to a6 and now knight d3 is a
threat and the game is taking on very
similar features but what's the critical
difference the knights on b6 not f6
there will be no sacrifice of any kind
in this position but eerie uh
resemblance to the game between byrne
and fisher and somehow magically the
bishop went from c8 and now may end up
on a6 anyway on the very next move
amazing we're going back 52 years in
time
and that's one of the great things about
chess we can relive some of the great
ideas from the past and play like the
great players from the previous and many
previous generations
echoes indeed isn't that a remarkable
idea i like it very very much learning
your classics is definitely an important
part but there you go again black is it
just holding but he's looking good in
this ani scary game i don't see anything
in this position right now i think that
anish's position is perfectly fine
maybe objectively white's position is
not worse he might have some chances of
pushing against the d5 pawn later right
but it looks like right now the dynamic
qualities of the position give geary a
perfectly good and playable game right
and i just wanted to say one other thing
about
that bobby fischer classic against
robert byrne
when i played over the game for the
first time
i was astounded by the move knight takes
g2
you know not taking the rook on d1 i
just didn't get it and knight takes g2
is stripping away this critical defender
of white's king
for bobby to have foreseen that move and
its consequences means he was looking at
the position 10 moves earlier and
where does he get this idea to go after
white's king white's got a pawn on h2 g3
f2 e3 knight on e2 bishop on g2 white's
king is the safe in a bunker as you
could possibly imagine and suddenly
stripped bare it was really an amazing
game for me and it made a huge
impression it's always funny how things
change because we were just going back
to the same point of how chess has
evolved and for me as a chess player
that was definitely brought in the
internet generation with all these
classics that i've already looked at
having the pawns on e3 f2 g3 always
screams to me danger
really like i i just look at the
position i'm always worried something's
going to be sacrificed on f2
i mean it's three years
it's something that i've seen so often
in so many classical games that's
happened in my own games that i'm like
okay i have to i have to be very careful
so it's funny that you know back in the
day uh such a sacrifice almost unthought
of and like looked crazy but for me it
was like okay yeah obviously i'm
standard standard look at all of the
look at all these games in the database
that prove that there's actually a lot
of dangers of sacrifices that white can
face a lot of danger and i think that
okay topalov's going to be rather safe
from it right now right because mainly
the knight on b6 is very far away from
the action but that doesn't mean that
giri doesn't have other resources and
particularly in his position the rook on
e2 feels so uncomfortable compared to
the other position because burn was able
to get the move queen d2n which made the
rook able to go to d1 right now it's on
e1 which is very uncomfortable since
it's going to be attacked by the knight
on d3 if it moves again then it's going
to be on the x-ray of the bishop on a6
so definitely some issues to solve for
topalov on the good hand as we said the
knight is on b6 which i think is rather
mediocre but okay right
out of play right black can't have
everything right
well you need to defend the pawn on d5
by the way uh alexander grishik has
played bishop e3 attacking the pawn on
c5 looks likely to go into some of those
positions that we saw maurice
well we were talking about eerie
resemblances to things past
take a look at this one this one is
bizarre as well remember we talked about
last year's game that carwana played
against aronian and he won this fine
game in the sink field cup and when he
played the opening at first we thought
what kind of bizarre stuff is this he
took on e6 then he played this move b4
knight c6 bishop d2 and suddenly he did
this sequence where he migrated after
knight to a2 all his forces over to
the queen side rook to b1 is the move
you i remember diaz is like what are you
doing and and then he played knight to
c1 and knight to b3 and he put
everything on this side of the board
very shortly by the way he ended up
attacking on this side uh after rook fd7
rook to c1 is this position i want to
take a look at look at this pawn
formation the pawns on d4
c3 looks like maybe you might just play
rook c1 right maybe you might play maybe
you might not you're holding back right
but remember look a3 and b4 your pawns
are up as well now if you may let's jump
to today's game
we'll go to this position
and look at this black is the one who's
hollowed on the queen side rook on the c
the pawn on d5 c6 break possible white
remember in the other game was looking
at the c3 break
and also the pawn formation a6 b5 in
this game from last year it was caruana
with a3 b4
really strange the pawn on d5 is just
like this game let's jump back to it
just just as quick reminder look at this
it's almost as though they switch colors
and they're playing the other color of
course there's some differences in the
middle in this open file but really
strange that it's now and current day
it's white playing black black playing
white so to speak and what is the
enduring feature however as in last year
is the maneuvering that's taking place
quiet maneuvering by caruana we were not
that impressed until the explosion
happened in his game last year now he's
played this move knight to h2 he's ready
to chip away at the light squares
black's light square bishop being off
the board he's going to play a move like
knight g4 potentially bishop g5 trade
off because there is this permanent
weakness on either the c6 square or
potentially this d-pawn nothing yet to
write home about but certainly we're
seeing the past reflected in the present
over and over again this is what we live
for as players is why we study these
games from the past so we can see the
patterns matching and potentially give
us a guide for how the position should
be played
absolutely this break on c6 seems like
it was so natural but levon is taking
his sweet time about getting over it i
mean the subtleties i'm sorry to say too
sophisticated for me
uh i love those echoes of the previous
game
reflected in today's game but help me
out here
why after you've played all of these
preparatory moves you you slid uh lavone
slid his queen over to c8 he's put it on
b7 understandably
and he's brought his rook to c8 it's
clear to everybody he's preparing this
counter punch c7 c6 it's almost like a
boxer winding up you know the right hand
is coming
h2h3 it's like white has ran out of
useful moves he's played the move h3
which as we know
in a closed rui uh is very useful for
white
rook b8
the only uh way i understand that movie
is he wants to get an a6b fight but why
on earth
hasn't he landed his blow c6 what
is it why
why not play c6 well my opinion is that
right now it's kind of a war of
attrition
the thing is that everybody's trying to
make useful moves right and the thing is
that caruana at some point will kind of
run out at some point either he'll play
rook d2 rook d1 and then if i don't play
c6
i can ask you why did you put your rooks
on
[Music]
it's up to white because he is white to
create something so you see that karana
starts maneuvering with h3 knight h2
starts bringing stuff to the king side
to actually create something because
imagine that levon never does anything
he starts shuffling back and forth
bishop f8 bishop e7 which is for example
just for example
for argument 6. then
caruana needs to do something in order
to change the character of the position
and once he's diverted some pieces away
from the center then it becomes more
obvious for black to play c6 the problem
with a lot of the c6 breaks and other
reload passes for example the one we
looked at earlier is that if you don't
play it in that move you're never going
to get it in right in this case
you got all game you're going to you
don't play c6 whenever you feel like it
no i get it very very well uh
said out alejandro that uh it's the
necessity if you will
is on white shoulders to do something
and black doesn't have to necessarily
commit himself but i'm saying
after the move c7 c6
i'm thinking of
sicilian
style sacrifices where in case you do
trade on the c6 square well i've got i
remember maurice and i
were in uh new york city together
it was a computer match not the deep
junior match and not not the deep blue
match i beg your pardon it was a deep
junior match
gary kasparov had this great sicilian
where maurice was shouting out loud
money moved rook takes c3 money move
and gary played it
and we were all you know wild in
anticipation of these exchange sacrifice
tactics and then the players agreed to a
draw yeah you know like we were crushed
you know like but look isn't this a
classic setup
where if white isn't careful rook takes
c3 sacrificing the exchange going for
knight takes e4 black gets a huge
initiative
a pawn and a damaged queen side
structure
am i missing something here what would
be
white's reaction to c6 i mean again i
don't think that c6 has any problem with
it i think it's just the fact that
imagine that you put in rook b8 and
knight h2 on the board and what ironian
is saying is that his moves would be
slightly more useful useful than karate
you're going to get eventually the same
ideas that's not going to change
but he wants it in such a small minute
little differences on the board that
might make his position favorable
compared to making the c6 break
immediately so i think all of your ideas
are going to be playing
on the board it's just that they're
going to be seen in a very slightly
different way as
white is going to be forced away from
the center at some point just to create
something and black's gonna be slightly
better prepared okay got it except i'd
have to disagree
the reason i disagree
is in the position that i'm talking
about
after the move c7 c6 just putting it on
the board one more time with the rook
takes on c6 i'm sitting there saying to
myself the knight on f3
is not
really well placed if we imagine the
battle
is taking shape over
you know who controls the d5 square then
the knight is not contributing to that
battle in other words i can see the move
bishop g5
and you want to take and establish
control your knight on f3 is less fuse
useful now if we go to the game's
position after rook v8 car iwan has
played knight h2 now he wants to play
knight to g4 and the battle of the d5
square the knight actually has a useful
function that might be true so that's
why i'm saying you don't really know c7
c6 becomes less
attractive maurice
you're the tiebreaker on this one my man
and you you know where it lies you know
i mean you got to support me on this
well i'm going to defer to the
all-seeing engine which says that you
are both correct
in
the fact
is but this is the reality aronian if he
plays c6 he could lead himself into a
line where kharan is actually just fine
it's maybe an equal position it's not
really that dynamic for black
white is just fine if he waits he's also
just fine so the point that alejandro is
making may be actually the more the more
important one because
aronian is saying let's let's play a
little bit let's see what you've got if
your position you know it's one of those
things where you could be all dressed up
with nowhere to go and if your position
doesn't lead anywhere if you're trying
if you get this good position you see
that a lot happen in hedgehog style
positions where wife's position is good
but it can't do anything if he makes if
he tries for anything aggressive it just
backfires this kind of position where
black here is saying i can wait i can
wait let's see what you do let's see
your next few moves and you look around
there are no obvious pawn breaks for
caruana even in this position
what is the pawn break
how do you improve the pieces even if
you get rid of this knight let's say
where's the break you know where's the
beef where's the break uh what's the
deal white has no pawn breaks at all
that make any sense f4 is not it doesn't
look quite right you're not going to get
any attack on this side there seems to
just be nothing immediate or or even
long term for white how do you move your
pieces meantime black is the one who
always has c6 in his pocket so that's an
important point here
again though let's go to this other game
it looks like it has indeed happened and
again shane shades of bern fisher the
bishop is now on a6 and the queen's on
d2 which also happened in that game the
difference is two differences this
bishop was on a3 in the game this knight
was on f6 i'll point out yet another the
pawn was on h2 not h3 so clear
differences here black of course can
play rook to c8 there is this minus the
knight on b6 often is a terrible piece
in chess particularly in these d-pawn
structures with the pawn on b3 you got
to say this knight we're not happy with
if white plays a female why can easily
play a few moves bishop b2 rook to c
rook to c1 when knight d3 is not a move
rook to d1 white can make a few
improving moves this night
is a problem we like to pick it up and
drop it somewhere else maybe like sneak
it into c5 when the guy's not looking
unfortunately it can't quite move yet
because the d-pawn is always under
pressure so as excited as we might be
for black's position resembling fisher
fisher's position against byrne there is
just a little slight issue with this
knight but maybe the dynamics of being
able to d3 will keep the balance for him
as bishop f1 by the way is not a good
move because it also weakens the king
side a bit too much so an interesting
game certainly still a long way to go
well thank you very much and i i feel
that you won the title on that one
between
uh our ourselves in the discussion of
fabi versus levon yeah we still have a
lot of interesting games and i think
that topalov's position it's not
particularly dynamic even though he's
known as a very dynamic player but the
fact that he's able to use this
knight against geary the fact that the
knight on b6 is so mediocre at the
moment really gives him the opportunity
to maybe create something and right now
i see that gary has played the move
knight d3 right it's a very curious move
because it seems uh a little bit on the
middle side okay the knight is already
on d3 which i think he could have done
at any point so just going back uh a
move you think he could have kept that
option right it seemed like rooks
very natural he could have played
immediately right so i think that after
knight d3 i'm not so sure if he's
thinking
about
well it just seems counterintuitive that
you would have moved your knight all the
way around the board to capture peace
that never developed you know the bishop
on c1 and it doesn't seem now at the end
of the day you've lost the dynamic
something's gone wrong maurice
absolutely
share some thoughts with us please
well again
the most important trade in all of chess
when i see it i know i keep sounding
like a broken record
bishop takes knight so in this position
i know you guys were thinking down he's
not going to do that and give up your
great bishop but it was the first move i
looked at i always look at this move
because it changes the position so
dynamically that you just have to look
at it and the engine didn't show it at
first in fact the engine still disagrees
that this is the best move until you
make a move now rook c8 is the move the
engine wants to play no knight takes c1
that just helps white uh improve the
position but let's take a look at this
move bishop takes knight what's this
about pawn takes and now you give the
engine a chance to breathe a little bit
what would you do and then it comes up
with the move queen to f6
queen to f6 hitting this pawn on d4 and
challenging white to defend it just how
are you going to protect your pawn that
looks like it's going to be a free pawn
how are you going to take it well if you
decide to grab a pawn yourself well you
can start resigning pretty quickly
because bishop takes d5 is now made by
queen takes d4 hitting the rook hitting
the bishop on d5 and that's it black's
winning so queen f6 how do you defend
the pawn it's just simply not easy at
all you don't want to start making crazy
moves like knight to e2 because you
block the f2 square and that's all she
wrote
he could do that right now what do you
do after queen f6 in fact the engines
giving a4
giving away the pawn as the best move
saying this is the way to play and the
times get sharp very fast look at this
line a5 knight to d7 and now
rook to a4 out of nowhere but the
engine's still going back it's arguing
uh no big deal i'm hanging i'm hanging
with you and now the move knight takes
d5 this knight shows up on c5 and i
think we know black is fine in this
position very dynamic uh play rook a2 is
the move suggested now clearly black is
back in business crazy position for sure
but i think that's the move again we see
the chance for bishop takes knight
magnus missed it earlier his chance to
play bishop takes d5 i wonder now let's
see if
geary finds this very paradoxical but it
looks like concrete i mean giving up
your
dear bishop your g7 bishop in the
grunfeld whoa talk about paradoxical
we'll see if that happens
now an important point in this chess
game i'd definitely consider this movie
thank you yes bishop takes d4 i thought
it okay perhaps it's not super obvious
but i did think that after take on the
four queen f6 it's slightly awkward to
defend this pawn on d4 and just because
of the concrete necessities of the
position because the fact that white is
not developed very well like his
bishop's still on c1 his queen and rook
which are developed are hindered by this
knight on d3 it makes a lot of sense to
create this immediate pressure right
it's going to be
interesting to see if gear is actually
going to do it because he has
he has several options that are just
tempting however i think that if he were
going to play rook c8 he would have done
it before playing knight d3 i mean
that's just what my impression would be
so i'm seriously thinking that he's
going to take on d4 right now yes
exactly it's a
sometimes you get this
idea fixate as the dutch might say you
don't give up your fiance a bishop that
defends your king you know your dragon
bishop
uh but i recall uh well on numerous
occasions uh the great vladimir kramnik
uh
taking his catalan bishop you know on g2
and capturing a knight and you're going
you know you're giving up this great
piece but because of the very specifics
and again i think that's the computer
talking as well in modern chess
the very specifics of the position
require you uh
sometimes to uh take a paradoxical
decision and it seems like gary agrees
with all of us as he has taken on d4 wow
taking on d4 and he has played with six
almost immediately so there you go very
nice very interesting position between
one of the
leaders of here in the grand chess tour
as we can just take a quick look at the
standings for all of you that are just
joining us we have the standings of the
grand chess tour uh before london the
ball of fleets with 17 points after
winning in norway and a okay performance
i guess in st louis hikar nakamura with
two strong performances but neither of
them victories he espoused himself in
second place with 16 points one point
behind him the winner of saint louis
with the disastrous norway level
neronian magnus carlson coming from
another disastrous norway but a good
showing in saint louis where he got
second with 14 points then the most
solid player of the event no defeats
anish giri with 13 points any of these
players can easily take the tournament
with just winning the event and a
slightly favorable series of results
with the other players right right
behind anish giri arvishyan and mvl only
one point behind and
well tournament as they said in their
player interviews completely wide open
right and i think i'll definitely i have
to agree with the players because
they're very aware of the prize monies
and they know what's going on
uh to a person it seemed they said
anybody who walks away from london with
a victory will be the winner of the
inaugural uh chess tour yeah absolutely
yeah so very nice and queen f6 uh
beautiful insight i might add by anish
geary first dynamic very very
interesting to give up those bishops for
just a mere night but if you do look at
the specifics
you know that night on d3 and again we
talk about bobby fischer but also echoes
of uh gary caspara right with that
knight on d3 yeah in a world
championship match against anatoly
karpov one of the greatest
brilliancies i think in the history of
chess was that game where the knight on
d3 was this octopus oh yes i remember
him yeah and so we see again the power
of that knight and
um the queen coming to f6 well just
because of that i was thinking of
playing the move um bishop f1 in this
position just to get rid of it exactly
to get rid of it but i'm wondering if
i had wanted to play queen f3 queen f3
yeah because of this uh and
everybody who's ever had the experience
of
chess has always fallen for this tactic
where the queen is protected by a rook
yes and you have that interference
move rookie won shaq
costing your queen i lost a game against
vichy anand in exactly this tactic yeah
we were in time trouble and he whipped
out that rook move and i just groaned i
mean ah
so i was thinking of queen f3 right to
maintain and if you don't take
pardon me if you don't recapture this
bishop well no why did you give yeah
you're not going to do that so i was
thinking that after queen f3 you might
just want to say get the heck out of
here bishop g2 queen goes back to f6 and
they might just test
one another
uh how do you feel about a repetition
i'm not saying that after bishop f1
black doesn't have other choices and i
want to point out that actually after uh
bishop f1 yes there's a similar tactic
with queen takes d4 but i don't think it
quite works unfortunately the queen
instead of queen f3 queen takes d4 right
it doesn't quite work because right now
the queen on d4 is a tactical target so
first of all i don't have to take on
right through immediately i can just
play probably bishop b2 is winning a
piece something like that precisely
bishop v2 and
unfortunately black has put his uh
pieces in a pin yeah in a pin yeah so i
like this queen f3 idea just maintaining
the tension it definitely looks like one
of the more
dynamic ways of saying of doing things
although i have the feeling that even if
you just take on c1 black's probably
doing okay
you mean from the very start if i take
on c1
i think you have to take a look
let's say just for the moment you would
take on
f1
and this looks like a pretty
stable list
even maybe between f3
you know like posting up on f3 nobody
likes a queen sitting on the f3 square
so i mean it looks like black's gonna
have at least a couple of ways of being
okay maybe
maybe even more than okay so i think
you know he has to be careful of a
couple of lines where
he might fall into a worse position i
like this dynamic a4a5 that maurice
mentioned but it is very
counterintuitive to play for when you're
pawn on d4 the center of your position
is just hanging exactly might i then add
a question for you alejandro if i were
to play the move bishop b2
uh you couldn't play queen takes d4
because that transposed into the very
position that
but
bishop on b2 isn't threatening anything
there's no uh
there's no well there's nothing to be
afraid of well
maurice had pointed out that you know
knight takes d5 that that's a
a non-starter knight takes d5 bishop
takes d5 queen takes d4 the double
attack against the bishop and rook is
too
costly
but
the move pardon me the move bishop b2
does possess now
actually it doesn't it doesn't oh no why
not well let's say that i play the move
rook ac8 okay you cannot take on d5
because i take on d5 yes bishop takes d5
from black's winning after knight takes
b2
oh
very good now the bishop on a6 is
activated rookie 2 is completely over
so you're still not running the pawn i'm
still not threatening so bishop b2 then
has no sense
behind it oh my and maurice actually has
some insight in rats another interesting
pawn structure
well it was an interesting pawn
structure now it's just turned into a
snooze fest because it looks as though
they're going to a quick draw here the
game between
magnus carlson and mvl uh did happen a
little burst of excitement the move
bishop to d3 was responded to by the
move bishop to c6 attacking the rook and
then rook takes on b4 and getting his
pawn back and after castles it looks as
though magnus has played the very
interesting rook to d4 and he's
guaranteed to be able to play the move d
by the way bishop a6 bishop
b5 hitting a6 and this bishop is on tap
so be careful for that because of the
pin but easy enough to get out of uh in
this position moving the queen away
although there are some potential
dynamics after this move that black has
to
bl that white has to look out for so i
shouldn't have spoken so quickly about
the snoozefest the move queen to f3
looks like you're covering everything
looks like it may be a draw suddenly the
move bishop takes on e4 appears out of
nowhere and this bishop is overworked
after bishop takes queen takes on this
square but the problem here is after
this check king over and now queen h4 uh
mate hello and also f6 with perpets in
the position and black has to bail out
and allow the perpetual in this line at
the worst after the king moves so it
looks as though the lines are just
typical schwesnikov a
small burst of excitement and then
suddenly it's a draw to prepare and so
what that one is definitely going the
quiet route the lines you guys mentioned
are absolutely right but the game i mean
that is in the geary game it looks like
you could easily see a perpet in that
game
very easily but take a look at this one
that we're so intrigued by from the get
go the c6 break the c6 brake when is it
going to happen well now knight h2 with
the idea of going to g4 would you have
suspected this next move as h5
out of nowhere on this side
demonstrating this attack preventing the
knight from going to the g4 square
the engines don't like it at all and for
one thing you weaken this g5 square
permanently knight f3 can be played in
g5 you'll never be able to kick the
night out if you don't if you want to
seems like a weird move
but nevertheless it's still a question
of does white
have anything specific can he still wait
around black that is play g6 and i
wonder what are you up to white what are
you trying to do it doesn't seem like
you're making any progress at all in the
position so still a turgid battle here
for sure in muddy waters the rest of the
games
developing quite slowly this one has
been slow for a while looks like adams
has equalized pretty much and nakamura
in that other position as well looks
like black is perfectly okay in that
weird berlin a lot of game left to play
wow thank you
uh maurice and uh as far as the move h7
h5 is concerned
where really surprised me was in a lot
of sicilians specifically the english
attack with f3
that black
played h5 and as a sicilian player i was
sitting there going you know you can't
play a move like h5 whereas in this
particular case i remember when i was a
kid
and i got these bulletins from walter
sean brown
of the soviet championships he would
mimeograph or xerox these bulletins and
these were like solid gold you know like
the soviets had these you know 18 player
20 player all all round robin play the
soviet championships lasted for months
and in many brayer variations black
ended up playing g6 and h5 especially
in the breyer so this move i actually
can understand i took me
i was it was much harder for me to
understand the h5 as black and sicilians
well it seems to be definitely the main
line reality
yeah i was talking to
i believe i want to say i was talking to
paris
who just wrote a fabulous series on uh
e4 for white a very very hard work he's
gone into it and he was mentioning how
yeah everybody's playing h5 and it seems
to actually overtake
um the other barriers just as the main
line of the sicilian so when you say
that h5 is the main line of the main
line of the sicilian you're like well
you know chess has changed a little bit
a little bit a lot of it
the five is definitely a move i
considered here but i was actually
afraid of just g4 like i thought car
runner would just bust out g4 in this
position
i mean you know in
the in the modern day
game and we we see this so often
like this uh game itself it's sort of
like you're seeing the players
not burning bridges they try to keep
their options as much as possible g4 is
crossing the rubicon okay do you think
that's too much
i know i don't know i'm just saying that
you you
pawns don't move backwards the immortal
words of victor course noise so uh you
you were thinking that after g4 h takes
g4 you know white might set up some good
attacking lines down the h file
i was thinking that okay black would
say okay now i'm going to take a
possession of the g5
you're probably playing
knight f3
and now
you know this this um
this delay if you will of the move c6
i
don't know how to evaluate this uh
knight goes back to
f5
for me it looks costly for black to have
put so many pieces on the queen side
when now you cannot break on
c6 at all so i understand that my dark
squares on the king side are weak but
the reason that i'm so fond of doing
something like this is that now c6 looks
ridiculous because if i take and giving
up
squared to my knight right fabiano
decided not to go for this route he
decided to go for
the more computer approved variation of
knight f3 trying to take advantage of
the weekend g5 square a little bit
quieter variation i think more of his
style he's not the type of player that
as you say burns his bridges right with
a move like g4 but okay he'll go for a
quieter approach which also looks
perfectly playable he always has the
ability of playing g4 at a later date so
maybe he will consider it in the future
for now he's going to play knight f3 and
it seems like we're going to go back
very quickly to the geary game that's
right maurice ashley has some updates
for us in that
position well there is some spooky stuff
going on in that game it's actually
fascinating to look at remember this
line we talked about the pawn on d5 on
d4 excuse me dropping and allowing the
pin to take place well it looks as
though topolof can do it in a very weird
way we've seen him do this before i saw
him do it i think it was the game
against nakamura last
in this year's tournament anyway the
idea of i'll give you a pawn but i'll
get weird play it was against nakamura
but i don't remember if it was this year
last year anyway queen to f6
a4 has been played
go ahead take my pawn if you want it go
right ahead now look at this line queen
takes d4 and in this position i'm not
going to play a5 this is the bizarre
point instead of playing a5 it's
possible here i'm not sure he's he's
seen it but it's possible here to play
bishop f1 by the way the game between
between carlson and vashila grav looks
like it's going to end in a draw and it
is going down that perpetual check route
that we talked about earlier that game
is ending in perpetual check so that
game will be a draw let's get back to
something more interesting though knight
to d7
this piece is hanging uh wasn't was not
hanging to the tactics that we talked
about but now the the move bishop to b2
remember this position you guys
discussed something similar eerily
similar and now it's not easy but take a
look at this line knight seven e5 looks
like i'm clamping down i'm grabbing my
knight protection oh i'm by the way
threatening this move what are you gonna
do
bishop back to g2 now that's just ultra
weird i mean that's strange there you
see the draw in that game as we
mentioned we predicted that would be an
easy draw and no problem there
now bishop to g2
on the board
now and bishop b2 now blocks up a pawn
but his knight is funny it's in the hand
in the cookie jar but how do you get out
how do you unpin well rook 88 was
suggested by the engine and now this
really spectacular move rook a2 if toppo
is going to find these moves i mean this
is 2 900 3 000 chests going on here rook
to a2 getting his rook from on this line
but also protecting his queen and now
asking black to find a move how do you
get out of this position how do you
untangle your queen is on d4 there may
be a night move at any point to hit on
your queen with some kind of tempo
knight b5 is the key move now we wonder
why a4 was played a to give the a2
square for the rook and also to put the
knight on b5 and now the variations is
that look at it with the engine it just
gets bad for black a move like queen c5
for example trying to get out allows
bishop to a3 this rook ultra useful not
b1 but a3 guarding this bishop as well
keeping the queen on tap and now if
queen a5 knight to b5 and now this
knight's in some kind of danger the
trade of
knight b5 if queen takes d2 i believe
was the line then suddenly magically
this rook appears on this square and
there's pressure white's just blown up
suddenly with all kinds of lines there's
another variation to look at here as
well queen b4 right after rook a2 queen
to b4 is possible but that allows the
knight takes on d5 and queen takes d2
unfortunately has to take with this rook
but it's still good by the way a knight
f6 check threat and if you decide to
stop that check then there's this pin on
this line and also the move knight c7
and this nice protection is being eroded
moves like rook to e7 for example just
lose on the spot suddenly
back to f1 that bishop just going back
and forth on that line and this pin this
pin that one everything is under attack
strange things happening on this board
and the move a4 is already there and
queen takes d4 has indeed occurred in
the game will he play a5 or will he find
this
what's i mean that's just beyond world
class that's computer s for sure bishop
f1 with the variations we just looked at
it's absolutely incredible stuff guys
and i don't think black could really get
out of it it looks as though this piece
and this these two pieces have put
themselves there they're now there he's
not won a pawn but he's going to have to
defend very accurately if this move
bishop f1 lands on the chessboard
my gosh i remember this comment by
magnus carlson to describe
the game
between lavone aronian and this
swannathon and non that was played in
the tata steel this was like
and he called he described it as alien
chess
and this move bishop f1 we were talking
about how anish gary's knight on b6 is
misplayed it's not doing anything
and literally toppola forces the knight
to e5 right where you're giving a check
on f3 a royal fork
and this turns out to be good for white
i mean that would be the most
counter-intuitive attacking idea i've
seen since
the bonneroni and
vishy annan so an amazing game going on
uh brewing here between anish gary and
vessel and topalov
our leader right the tour it always
seems to me that topalov has a very
strange computer-like understanding of
chess i always look at his sacrifices
and his moves and it doesn't make any
sense to me but the computer's like yeah
that's that's really good yeah yeah yeah
i'm like well how did you think of this
but i like this idea of queen takes d4
bishop f1 it's it's always difficult for
black to
untangle and if he doesn't have anything
specific like a forced variation that
just untangles his pieces it goes a
little annoying to actually have to play
this kind of position bishop f1 makes a
lot of sense even though it doesn't
actually threaten anything i don't think
but it's uncomfortable it's
uncomfortable to see this position with
the queen on d4 or in this brand by this
and i'm wondering is it really not on is
it really not threading anything because
it's bishop takes d3 not a winning
threat
because the rookie oh when my queen was
on f3 i have the check mate on h1 yeah
with my queen on d4
uh so well that's not the reason
actually i'm sorry because let's say
that i play rook c8
i'll throw a move in rook c8 for example
that works that goes back to what i
wanted to say yeah roxy it will work
okay and then play group d
then yeah but rook s8 also works oh it
does yeah yeah for me it will work okay
so bishop takes d3 yes well now you have
rook takes c3 i guess that but uh just
uh share your your thought bishop b2
and i just i just maintained the fin
that's a nasty one pardon me and your
bishop protects the rook on any one so
then when this is now when there's no
threat at the end
of your king right i get it i get it
very good so yeah
since bishop f1 actually has a threat on
the board it becomes more natural to
play then for example it was a vague
idea of just playing bishop b2 on the
next move right because it's easier for
a human to just go bishop f1 i'm
threading something he must react right
then you have the move knight d7 which i
think is what maurice was recommending
precisely because you have to defend
this uh
knight straight three yeah against a
threat so suddenly it becomes a lot
easier to understand how to come up with
some of these moves and i think that
bishop f1
now that i think it has a threat becomes
more natural than pushing away the
knight which probably wants to go to d7
right right exactly maurice
in that line it's hard though because a5
followed by rook a4
that looks good that looks aggressive
it's hard to you play at a4 it feels
like you should play a5 like that pawn
should go down the board then bring the
rook up as well and those are tactics to
analyze and plus you win your pawn back
even in that line except black's play is
fine bishop f1 takes an incredible
measure of self-control to play to say
i'm not going to do anything i played a4
i said a but i'm not going to say b i'm
going to say something else and then i'm
going to come up with moves like bishop
b2 and rook a2
i don't think he's finding those moves
he finds those moves you know check
check uh is his phone or something some
kind i mean those those moves are
incredible those are like you said alien
chess
but to paulov i remember the game now it
was the game from last year's sink field
cup to apollo played against nakamura
this one is a lot more sensible though
in this position to paulov after the
move g6 by nakamura it looked nakamura
was doing fine and missed the sacrifice
earlier in the game
five pawns against five here to paulov
with no fear typical to paulov
throughout e6 on the board said you want
a pawn you can have it and after fe 6
queen to g4 attacking this pawn again
nakamura said you want it back somehow
no because i'm hitting your queen he
said no i don't want him back i never
wanted it back it was just a pawn sack
and he sacrificed to get this position
after rook f8 knight d to f3 and after
bishop d5 95 and it became very clear
why it was that he sacrificed his pawn
down upon he was nakamura didn't defend
precisely but still incredible pressure
in this position topolov went on to win
a fine game here so it's just his style
to paulov is one who says you pants
hans what a
and here he's saying the same he's given
the pawn up but he's in his element his
personal style it's typical to give away
pawns and of course
gary's probably more like you yes
old palm rubber grab it looks free but
he might find that there are going to be
some real challenges as this game
continues well i've always thought of
vessel and topolof as one of the world's
most dynamic players being number two in
the world former world champion
i mean all the he deserves all the
accolades he
he
he gets
um
he loves the initiative and he like like
maybe only alexi shearhoff would like
the initiative more and is willing to
sacrifice more than vessel the vessel
has his fair share of sacrifices he
really is a dynamic player and this
position
is simply wild uh that he has with anish
gary there's so many complicated lines
and that whole variation that maurice
was showing with bishop b2 rook a2 and
knight b5
right
no i mean i was having a hard time
understanding any of those moves in fact
they're weird to find but i think that
individually maybe they're not that hard
right because
as i was mentioning it's treating them
all together
with threats right right bishop f1
threatens a piece right then he goes
back to d7 bishop b2 is like the most
natural move on the board you want your
bishop on the long diagonal potential
threats on d5 when the knight goes to e5
well you're getting royal forked on f3
bishops
yeah you know stuff like this it's like
yeah on a row it's really hard to find
but if you go piece by piece yeah move
by the move yeah maybe it's not that
difficult that being said
it's still weird i'm just trying to
i'm just trying to justify how to get
there boy i i just gotta say
uh you know watching these guys play is
a thrill
the fact that they put some of these
astounding ideas to work it's it feels
like magic to me you know like wow how
do these concepts work
speaking of uh amazing concepts
i'm looking at this hikaru nakamura game
and i'm laughing because the king went
to d8 yes
then it went back voluntarily to e8 then
it was forced to return to d8 now i'm
seeing after this move knight e4 that
there's an idea by uh grisha to bring
his knight to g5 we may see this king
yet return once more first he defended
the pawn on c7 now the king returns goes
to show the king can be a very good
defensive piece the berlin is just one
of the weirdest execs and you can dance
with the king on the center of the board
and the team's like oh yeah i'm i'm
doing okay it's cool it's crazy it's
crazy maurice with us has some
information about the rating list
well just a couple of points i know that
it's not that significant but magnus
carlsen continues his decline this draw
lost him point eight rating points on
the 2700 chess dot com site you can go
to it yourself and vashea legrove has
gained 0.8 points so he continues his
march up slightly he is number 10 in the
world right now just below wesley so
who's number nine in the world and it
also shows on the side that these are
live in progress games they will go
blank when these games have concluded
another point i want to make very
quickly this book i just picked it up
myself great book for ins for
learning about structures this game this
book chess structures a grand master
guide by mauricio my name's sake in
spanish flores rios this is the kind of
book you want to look for it won't make
you into a specialist in any individual
opening but it will talk to you about
structures and that's very important to
know your structures as we've been
pointing out now getting back to the
wild action this game that ended in a
draw we showed that perpetual line in
fact uh the game after
the the game did go
as we said queen f3 bishop takes e4
and bishop takes e4 queen a6 he started
with check and he played queen f5 in
this position threatening a mate and
also threatening on f6 there is no
reasonable move but rook takes e4 and
the game ended in perpetual check
because of course white is down a rook
and can't do anything else so that looks
like a quiet draw this one looks like a
draw as well adams versus anand black is
just equalized very naturally and
nothing much in the structure so i think
both players are thinking this will end
up being a draw so those two games
notwithstanding the round is still
extremely exciting as we see
this position
let's jump to this since we haven't
talked about it knight to b6 h5 and
knight went back to f3 and now knight to
b6 aiming for the c4 square and that's
fascinating looking at how he's playing
this position he can always play c6 but
he's decided i'm going to keep the
pressure on it seems as though black is
the one that can improve his position
and white simply can't so white is
getting in that territory you talked
about alejandro except he's being even
more aggressive he's not just going to
sit around and wait he keeps making
forward-looking moves almost like a
little soft jab
what are you going to do as i make more
and more interesting threats and hopes
that the opponent opens up a bit too
much before landing the haymaker so we
see here that aronia thinks i'm just
fine i can play moves like h5 i don't
need c6 you can't do anything as white
where is the progress and
he may be right after all
um
yeah i'm confounded
it's a position where black just has so
many moves and white as i think i'm
still right about it you know still has
to prove something he still has to do
something in the position that's going
to at least make black uncomfortable
let me try okay let me throw out the
move rook d3 you spoke about this before
doing very natural well you you
mentioned that white could double on the
d file right you won't play the move c6
not for now ask then you will not ask
what the heck are your rooks doing on
the default well to borrow an expression
of gems uh jennifer shahadi that is uh
i've got ideas of a rover okay
i'll i'll uh i'll tell you up front that
that might be on my agenda all right
knight c4 at least you're honest about
it yeah well exactly knight c4 is not
the only idea of 9p6 i was actually
thinking since i'm a sicilian player uh
always sacrificing your structure
by opening the b line would actually
make the rook on v8 look like it was a
decent move right so i was thinking
knight a4 here
whoa
look at that one okay i definitely
didn't see that coming i mean you you've
caught me
way off guard
knight a4
reminding me that i have a little bit of
an issue
here on e4 so the
the grab takes takes
leaves this guy hanging and this guy
hanging
forcing the less than desirable vision
c1 i'm just going to keep on forward c6
now c6 really does have some
behind it
if i end up
taking queen takes
and suddenly again
you got a double hit
very nice knight a4 really caught me
uh sorry for the image there
with my pants down
didn't want to break you know it's early
in the morning but okay
the night a4 really took me by uh
caught me off guard very nice move and
it reminds white that
there are undercurrents
i've never
really been a great fan of this move
this bishop on uh e3
uh
do you think he'll just turn it off and
that's what i that was the question i'm
about to ask
by the way giving you a double option
c takes six isn't completely
uh
no it's it's definitely possible to take
with the c pawn just to open up the file
get the rook on c4 maybe the other one
on c8 think about b4 later there's
definitely a lot of options here for um
for black it definitely makes it more
static though and i'm always worried
that if i'm going to be settled with a
bishop on
e7 that i don't really want without
these 66 right it's going to be
hindering my bishop from going into this
awesome diagonal
b6 yeah so
things to consider i'm not saying it's a
bad move at all right but it's something
that i would actually have to be a
little careful about that in the long
run if white consolidates then suddenly
strategically he might be better simply
because he got a bad bishop
right so let's just go with for the
moment the standard right queen b6
rook d3 again uh almost begging you to
play c6 to justify what i'm doing in my
rook the problem now with the rover by
the way
with the absence of the dark square
bishop i'm not a big believer that this
rover is ever going to do anything on
the riding side
it
definitely takes the shine
off of my maneuver yeah strategic plan
having said that
your turn
are you going for a5 b4 or are you going
to do
something
it's hard to say in this position
definitely a5 before
is a possibility it's kind of one of
those positions where i would just play
a5 anyway and if i'm not going to play
b4 it doesn't really matter if i was
okay anyway right a useful move useful
move to always keep the tension you know
the thread is stronger than the
execution
so a5 just to have before on the table
might be a possible move i still am not
really afraid of any of your moves and i
think that a5
improved my position slightly yeah so i
like the move a5 okay again it's yeah it
just doesn't feel like white has
the crisp clean threads that you would
like to see and it's definitely
a position corona wants to press he
wants to get back on the board as well
these guys are not exactly playing for
fun they're definitely paying for a
large sum of money as we take a look at
the prices here at the london chess
classic three hundred thousand dollars
of prize fund in the each tournament
this being the third tournament yes 900
right and at the end of this event 150
000 extra dollars will be split by the
top three finishers i believe the top
price is a hundred thousand
was it seven was it seventy five seventy
twenty five yeah i think it was seventy
five thousand dollars so definitely a
lot of money on the line especially for
the one that not only takes this
tournament but takes the entire chess
tour right and for now vesseling to
paula from levon aronian are leading on
the earnings this year on the grand
chester both taking home
90 thousand dollars karan nakamura
nothing shabby 80 and well the rest are
splitting the rest of the pot right but
1 million 50 000
in this inaugural
tour i mean quite a bit of money players
are players are pleased maurice
well guys i'd like to get you in on this
discussion because i'm i'm fighting with
the engine and it's just you know it's
got its own mind
just one of those things uh where it
just doesn't listen and say okay let's
do this sometimes you need to talk with
somebody who's going to talk back as
opposed to just say this move this move
all right in this position i thought the
best move was to move knight to d2 i
thought an interesting move was to move
knight to d2 i've been trying to get my
knight over to this side of the board
because this c6 square really is
interesting to me and the idea by
possibly knight b3 knight a5 knight c6
although maybe i'll get up there and
find that again i'm
you know in purple rose but got no party
to go to uh this move knight d2 though
still
if it gets to this square at the right
time could be a good one the the point
to this move critically is that this
knight a4 move
alejandro is a good looking move but
after takes take suddenly b4 shows up on
the board and i don't think you're going
to be too thrilled by this particular
position
the pawn's ready to go to b4 maybe
knight c4
so what do you guys do here knight to d2
looks
like an idea and also i want to trade
this bishop for one of these knights at
some point not for this guy i'd rather
trade it for this guy and get the light
square grip i feel like if white gets a
light square grip maybe even this knight
will show up here but i don't like it
here because g6 is too easy
i just feel like there might be a little
pressure after the move knight to d2
right well you're gonna have to see what
kirana has in store 92 looks definitely
like an interesting move irony will have
to react to
we actually have jennifer shahadi live
in london with our world champion magnus
carlson
so tell us a little bit about the
opening today
uh well it was the session code it's
quite a forcing opening uh
then well my team usually plays the
mission p5
7 so i was a little bit surprised but
then
um yeah he sort of confused some lines
and
very early on he was
clear that i had no problems i was
searching for an advantage but i
couldn't find it
there was nothing clear so
i
decided to force it off
all right so
um what do you like most about playing
in london
um well i haven't been here for many
years but uh
i like the fact that i won it's very
nice
great that was the year that you broke
gary kasparov's record for the highest
rating right yeah uh i yeah i won three
times so that was one of them so
many good memories
now what's different about this band
uh it's a longer tournament it's a
stronger tournament
so you've been doing a lot of mainstream
interviews for the telegraph and you did
a tv show yesterday and i noticed in one
you said that you wanted to play more
intuitively and more by instinct do you
feel that you got off to a good start
there no
there wasn't so much room for creativity
today
um
yeah draw with lights
and who in this tournament do you feel
like is going to be in good form
i don't know it's hard to say after one
round
so
um
so what is this about winning the grand
chess tour or winning the london chat
classic
for me it's about finding
[Music]
all right great thank you
carlson being magnus but yeah he was on
the bbc
he's really one of the players that for
me
like gary kasparov has really elevated
in the
mainstream media
right they don't really pay attention to
chass and chess grand masters but when
you say gary kasparov you talk about
name recognition when you say magnus
carlsen today you really talk about name
name recognition and going on the bbc
and being interviewed is proof positive
of that well and i want to ask you
something is it
is it part of the responsibilities of
being a world champion absolutely
because and this is something i didn't
say but jude polgar did say in an
interview once that vishyanan was not a
good world champion
and the reason for that is that outside
of india
he didn't do much
to say to the world i'm world champion
look at me
bring the attention to me
i
you know there i have a little bit
trouble because in fact to my mind vishy
has been a great world champion i mean
he was a great world champion he's a
consummate gentleman at the board
in his public appearances
uh he's really working with children
he's all the stuff he does you know has
really really been good
it didn't capture the the the western
attention you know he didn't capture
let if you want to make a criticism
vladimir kramek the same thing very
inwardly type of person i see gary
kasparov was larger than life i mean he
was outsized right very controversial
always good for a quote you know that
type of thing whereas with vishy in
terms of a quote he's going to give you
something like well it was a tough day
right
you know like really not blowing your
hair back right
so but i do feel very very strongly
that if you're a world champion in
basically any sport but most especially
chess you've got to be a great
ambassador for your sport and i hope so
you know one of the players that's
definitely vying to get that spot is
maxim bashar lagrav and we have him live
with jennifer shahadi from london
all right so tell us a little bit about
the game today were you surprised by the
opening
well i
expected that it was possible
i was already fighting for equality
which i barely managed to fight
do you feel extra pressure playing
against magnus
not really i mean
all the guys here are you know very
strong of course magnus is number one in
the
[Music]
uh
and yeah so what was the inaccuracy that
you're talking about
i just played a for night before
too quickly
it's basically
[Music]
um what does it feel like over the board
when you realize that moment and do you
like have like a sinking feeling or is
it just something where you're just
able to recover pretty quickly
but it's happened to that many times i'm
kind of used
now what's your favorite thing about
london
well i've
not been in london
so many times
any expectations that you have anything
that you think we're going to say
i don't know i'm really hoping for good
reasons
of course
that's not a really great start but it's
not a bad one either and
i will see if i can pick up um before my
arts
i have
for a few months now and
if so
i hope to achieve some some good stuff
now i know most of the players when
asked about math the math tie breaks and
the branches were standing they always
say they take it one game at a time but
i understand that you're really into
math so have you like calculated the
simulations and the chances that
different players are going to win
no i mean i wouldn't i mean i didn't do
any statistics to to figure out
something with
our expected results i mean it is
all about the tournament before the
punches
okay well very good luck and we'll talk
to you again
thank you
well i saw it start here for mvl who
draws i guess magnus says they both said
confusing maybe the variation a little
bit more right
which didn't allow him to really create
much out of the opening actually we saw
a couple of variations where we thought
magnus might even
slightly take over and i think that it
was kind of wise for mvl to bail out
with that draw right he did a very
opportune moment right exactly and uh
again
i thought it was ironic that uh
the interview with magnus that he wanted
to come and play creatively today he
fell into one of those variations where
everything is forced right and any
deviation from these forced moves would
be disastrous so
there was no creativity in the game and
it was simply a well-played draw
it happens it does and i'm going back
for a moment just taking a look at the
game of our tournament leader veselyn
topolov against
anish geary
this was actually a line of variation i
mean to say that maurice
had looked
at
some while ago
and uh
he
marisa just pointed out a variation
where it was useful from white's point
of view to have this pawn on a4
because after there was this crazy line
with bishop b2 and rook a2 and the
knights sometimes jump to b5 but on the
other hand it's so human you want to
just win your pawn back right i mean
the only piece
that's defending the d5 pawn is the b6
knight so if you didn't rush your pawn
up the board and play rook a4 knight
takes d5 you know
people would say oh you know like he's
using a computer or something crazy you
know so a5 very very natural uh human
move
and so we're anticipating this move
knight d7 current surprise gary's
thinking actually can he play rook c8 or
97 is just forced
it looks like 97 is forced
well let's just make sure of that
because rook c8 is a move you'd like to
play if you can get away with it but it
gives me a free tempo i think on bishop
b2 also right rook takes you can't
capture this way
because again that pin looks pretty
uh
decisive if you capture with the queen
it would be just so inhuman to allow the
parliament
to get to a7 you'd almost have to ask
yourself how on earth did that one get
to a7
you know no this looks terrible yeah i
have to play 97. right so 97 so what's
he thinking about oh he did play 97 okay
for sure we thought that was oops excuse
me my mouse is kind of whoa let me get
it i got to get my grippers on that
knight on b6
so i can move it and then clearly uh
besseline has rook a4
in mind that looks like the point behind
a5 after all is to clear this uh
diagonal yeah to get off of this
um and he did play rook a4 he just
played the move of course by the way
another thing that i like about vessel
and topolof's play
uh as a professional player at the board
when
he's
on his mojo when he's gonna get going
he plays quickly right he just doesn't
hang around and you know second guesses
his moves he really plays fast and for
example once again magnus carlsen losing
on time you know he's a fast player he's
he's very very practical and
when again he when he's thinking in a
forcing kind of manner he plays very
quickly so rook a4 what was the main
lines we were looking at were we playing
queenie five i think so to be fair he's
playing uh rather slowly today he did
well he only has 27 minutes left oh he
has played slowly so
he has 27 minutes and 34 seconds for 18
moves which is not bad but it's not
exactly yeah yeah it's not it's not a
fast pace uh at all
um
no i think it was wasn't it bishop b2
well it's black to move so i think queen
e5 was the queen e5 by biggie pardon i
might be wrong with that one but i
wanted to say the knight on d7 went to
c5 and some of the variations right so
we were were we gunning for night takes
but then
we got knight c5 and things heating up
again that's why we're gonna ask maurice
ashley well let's do those variations
well i've been i've been go drilling and
drilling and drilling with the engine
going down deep looking to try to figure
out the form here guys it's a confusing
position but it looks as though vasili
and topolo has judged this correct
correctly from a practical standpoint he
doesn't have to find super genius moves
he just has to find genius moves and and
then he'll be fine lisa gets his pawn
back in this line and black still has
work to do in this line so let's take a
look uh going back
to this position no let's go back even
further here after rook a4 the engines
are giving queen e5 as the best move and
now knight takes d5 got my pawn back
it's in my hand no problem now the
question was this move knight seven to
c5 this looked like a challenge to
white's position why well the rook's
under attack and the pawns under attack
this is a fork these two pieces will be
under attack and this bishop will be
hanging how is he going to handle that
move the engines are saying that there
are a couple of moves that make white
well there are plenty of moves that make
white much worse but if white really
wants to keep the advantage the key move
is this bizarre one
rook to h4
way on the other side of the board could
you have guessed the a1 rook was going
to be on h4 in just a few moves kind of
bizarre
but the more important point is well
what happens after knight b3 thank you
very much i'm forking your queen and
bishop what's the big deal here you
might have thought it was queen eight
six and you got all happy and excited
until the guy says yeah and go ahead
mate me i dare you and
you might look and take when he moves
over there's no mate there's there's
nothing there and the queen can always
go back to g7 the position is barely in
balance uh it looks like there's some
lines that lead to potentially a draw
with something like this in check and
pick off this knight and white is
fighting for equality there after queen
g7 okay that doesn't work but the key
move here remember he's lost his pawn so
it's like he won the pawn back the key
move here and winning
is queen to g5 and i mean winning this
is huge
why is that
knight f6 check with the rook coming
down is suddenly on the board and be
careful don't put your king on f8
because knight d7 check picks it off so
this problem
suddenly arises and after bishop takes
we have the knight f6 problem with the
knight c7 problem and it's white for
choice suddenly in the position white is
totally winning here you can look for a
while and not find any way to defend
yourself properly because of these two
threats from afar rookie 6 still allows
this move so this position here rook to
h4 this is the one after queen e5 rook
h4 that
that
sorry after knight c5 and rook h4
happening this position is tricky
for black to find great moves the
natural move knight takes c1 looks like
the best move but queen takes c1 and
even these variations get a little crazy
i hate to put too many of the analysis
i've been doing on the board but it's
important to take a look at some lines
right here knight b3 again is bad
because of queen to a3 and this knight
is trapped it has no way to go anywhere
back home you can
mess around with some variations that
just don't work with with uh
bishop to e2 and all that so that's not
a great line and if you don't take the
other move is bishop to e2 this might be
the best way for black to play is to
challenge this rook and try to get the
knight in on this square and your rook
is really short of squares as a matter
of fact just to be careful but the
engines give this crazy sacrifice
exchange sack i call it crazy but he's
even in material but he sacrificed an
exchange so that he can play this move
a6
huh what well the main point is this
knight is beating all the black pieces
if it ever gets it on a dark square
you're in trouble this pawn is hanging
so if you take queen to c6 and suddenly
the move knight f6 is hitting this rook
it's hitting h7 and un incredibly white
is just better down a pawn and an
exchange and it's white for choice here
not winning but better for sure
according to the engines so
again crazy play it seemed as though
this line was more stable but it's gone
into something that just looks uh also
pretty insane but the more you look at
it the more you feel like yeah white
white can handle himself here if you're
ever stealing topology his level he'll
be able to find these moves as you call
it uh alejandro one by one one at a time
i i'll play this one it looks pretty
good and he should be okay meantime gary
as calm as he was after taking on d4
boy he looks deep and thought now and i
think he's realizing
there's danger in them there hills he
has to make sure that there's no
problems with any of the tactical
variations it seems like the computer's
finding ways but it definitely looks
like it's a little bit dangerous and
actually
there's no question about that when you
play a move like bishop takes d4 you're
weakening a lot of dark squares around
your king side it has consequences well
let's see if we pace for it meanwhile we
got jennifer shahadi live from oh we
don't have her just yet so yeah it'll be
interesting to see because as you said
bishop takes d4 just weakens so many
darts of the dark squares so this move
queen g5 when maurice put it on that was
nice it was nice but knight f6 check it
became obvious that yeah you're
weakening all your dark scores if i can
actually get a knight to give a useful
check then suddenly your position is
close to collapsing i think gary
definitely has to be careful in some of
these variations he's a very
he's one of those players that really
believes in his position yes a lot of
the times i remember we were analyzing
postmortem uh on the stingfield cup he
played the game against mvl
and everybody that came downstairs uh
magnus came downstairs and he looked at
the position it's like oh yeah mbl is
better and somebody else came downstairs
like oh yeah mbl is better the computer
gave mvl a slight edge at the end of the
game i think was a draw um and then each
gear came downstairs and he was like
wasn't i just better at this position
yeah and then i have the initiation
yeah i don't have an extra pawn right
and i think that he's a player that's
very confident in his positions which is
a good thing and a bad thing because
sometimes you actually have to be
careful and be like well this position
is actually not that good i gotta
actually be careful of certain
variations
and i think this is the type of position
where i think
it's easy to underestimate white's
initiative right and it seems like we do
have jennifer shahadi ready from london
okay got it yeah got it okay
thanks guys i'm here with malcolm payne
the organizer of the london chess
classic so however did you choose these
dazzling colors today
well it occurred to me that i've worn
the same suit two years in a row i
thought three would be unlucky so you
know i went shopping well this year is
very special this year is the grand
chess tour right so how does it feel
different than
so many other times that you've
organized and been at the helm of this
great tournament well it's the strongest
taunt we've ever had mainly because
being part of the grand chess tour
ensures you get nine of the world's top
10 or 11 players so this is the highest
category we've ever had in the uk it's
wonderful we also have this added bonus
of the 150 000
uh prize at the end of the year it's
climaxing in london and you know the
players have even more to fight for than
usual yeah and it's great that it's a
tournament within a tournament right so
it's never going to be boring right
exactly there's something's going to
change you can have several draws but
something will change for example the
rating performances of the players
effects significantly whether they
qualify for next year's talk
so i know you can't really have
favorites as the organizer but is there
any player that excites you the most
just their their style or their
personality i mean i've always liked
hikaru because you know his
never say die approach plays for a win
in every position and also he's played
some of the most incredible games here i
mean we always remember the king's
indiana game against kramnik which you
know always just goes down as one of the
most fantastic games we've played in
ever played on these shores actually i
know you had a kind of an equivalent
against wesley
which was but i think actually the game
against kramnik was even more explosive
uh made a deep impression on me at the
time
yeah nakamura we know you're saying that
for the american fans watching this
right
well
what else uh what else are you excited
about i know this is a bigger festival
than of course this amazing tournament
there's also a lot of other things going
on right tell me about that it is
remarkable that every aspect of the
london chess classic is sold out so we
have as i'm sure you've been around to
see a huge chess festival going on we've
had over a thousand entries for all the
side events we've got a few day rated
open we've got weekend tournaments we've
got weekday tournaments we've got junior
tournaments we've got amateur
tournaments and it's completely sold out
we've got a chess conference going on
looking at chess and society people
bringing their ideas and experiences of
chess in prisons chess with addiction
chess for asylum seekers and refugees
and of course chess in schools which is
one of the basic basic points of the
whole thing we're backed by the charity
chess in schools and communities and
that's completely sold out so actually
next year i'm looking around thinking
i've got to find somewhere bigger
to hold this to hold this wonderful
tournament wow so chess is getting more
popular yeah that's the conclusion i
mean it was a bit of a bit of a
breakthrough uh yesterday night when
magnus got on something called the one
show which is one of the popular most
popular shows in in the uk in prime time
at seven o'clock in the evening it's on
every every weekday it has between four
and a half and six million viewers and
everybody in britain knows the one show
so for magnus to get on that was really
a bit of a breakthrough for chess and
actually in a way for magnus that's
amazing well we'll keep going with that
now i know at heart you're still a chess
lover because with all of your
responsibilities your eyes are glued to
the games as well so what do you think
today what is the the game of the round
well i think i've got a feeling that the
the nakamura sorry excuse me the um the
aronian uh caraway carawanda white
against aronian is a bit of a slow burn
that one but now i just noticed that
there's a little bit of action on the
queen side and lots of pieces are still
on the board there isn't going to be a
liquidation there i think that we'll see
we'll see some we'll see some
interesting play there that mickey adams
as keeping visciana and just keeping
with no difficulties and uh i think
geary against it looks like it might
liquidate to a draw there there are some
there are some interesting possibilities
perhaps nakamura against grisha has got
you know the capacity to become a little
bit wild because as we know berlin
defense might look very dull but black
has these two bishops and you know his
white bishop when you see that white
bishop on c6 and it's looking all the
way down to h1 you just think
there's potential for some for some
dangerous tactics here too absolutely
and then in that carrana game that you
mentioned that one intrigues me too who
do you like do you like caruana or
arunian in that game it was funny so
carolina went knight h2 to go knight g4
and um
yeah and and erroneous at h5 no you're
not doing that here's all right i'm
going to go knight a2 and so then
aronian went c6 to try and try and block
that off i
don't know i just
slightly prefer to be black i know if
you look at it black's bishop isn't very
good but black's pieces just look a
little bit more active to me and also a
ronin in e4 e5 positions i mean he's
so brilliant at them he seems to play
them better than anyone in the world i
think so i slightly favor him perhaps
you said i'm a chess level you know last
year i managed to play as well managed
to sneak a few games one tournament i
haven't mentioned is we also have a huge
rapid tournament on the final weekend
with 20 20 plus grand masters um lots of
people over 2 600 and last year i
managed to sneak a few games in in that
tournament and hopefully i'll do the
thing okay so i was asking if you were
going to play in that as well all right
well we're here with malcolm payne at
the london chess classic organizer and
uh player so yeah okay thanks
of course when i'm in st louis i like to
play blitz outside we'll be hitting you
up for some more wisdom
thanks guys back to you guys in the
studio well we mentioned him as a player
but he's not just a chess player or a
slob
very strong player as well and a chess
lover and i think it's a good time
actually to take our second break of the
day and we will be right back with the
initial round from london
remind me when we return
uh to tell a story of self-confidence
and anatoly karpov it's a good one stay
tuned
[Music]
so
welcome back we're here live on the
first round of the london chess classic
the final tournament in new year's
year's grand chess tour
and we have a lot of interesting games
so far developing we've had a little bit
of an update in the nakamura game we
only have one result so far as maxine
bashir lagrave drew in a complicated
fashion cough against the world champion
magnus carlson
yeah and uh before we get right into the
games i did want to share the story of
self-confidence and how confidence is
critical in not just the professional
chess grand masters lives but in all
types of sports you have to have a great
deal of self-confidence
and i recall these melody amber
tournaments that were played in monaco
joe von ostrom brought together the
world's elite players to play blindfold
and rapid chess against one another
and
there was this game
where vichy anon was white
against anatoly karpov and it was an
isolated queen pond position
and after 15 moves very very standard
position and the players came and
analyzed with all the elite grand
masters gathered around and making
kivitzing comments and
and nan said well in this position i
just kind of hit a brick wall i didn't
know how to
increase my advantage and uh
anatoly i said advantage advantage what
advantage i stand better
and this she said no i stand better
and like two school kids going back and
forth they argued like that for a few
minutes
and then vishy said
look
anatoly
this is the game between you anatoly
karpov you were white against tigran
petrossian it was the 1972 ussr
championship
and this was the same position
anatoly was stunned everybody was quiet
you know and totally said my god you're
right
okay but after a little maneuvering soon
i will be better
so this is self-confidence on how
critical it is now turning to the game
is the berlin it's an amazing um
uh weapon uh amongst the world's elite
players we did see this move bishop c6
knight g5 and i was saying you look at
this king dance and the king has to go
back to ea there's no choice there's no
other way of defending this df7 square
that makes any sense you just put a
bishop on c6 don't want to put it back
so we've seen this king kind of uh
uh go oscillate between the e8 and d8
squares
white played the natural f4 so this is a
crushing f5 i mean five's on the board
yes you can
and then suddenly this counter-intuitive
blockading move f5
giving up then the e6 square
uh
caused us to take a deep breath and it's
the number one move on the computer's
hit list as the best move that's what
i'm saying that i cannot play yeah the
berlin
but now we see something
okay
white
grisha you know develops his rook and we
see this move g6 solidifying f5 right
and if the knight ever gets to f5 for
example let's do a reasonable move
knight c4 bringing back our knight from
siberia it makes a lot of sense takes
takes
knight comes to f5 well
you got ideas of rook h4
check and mate in the position so we got
to go bishop f2
and if icaru wants
he's got a simple
draw by repetition and i don't think
there's any reason for black to
immediately go for that do you even
think that he can push for some kind of
maybe he might even push you know you
stick your bishop on e7 you've got the
draw in the pocket so to speak
it's it's confounding it's just simply
confounding
the power of this light square bishop on
c6 now shows black completely dominates
the h file there is no way you can put a
rook on h1 any anytime soon so yeah i
can see how christian could even get in
trouble if he over process now he has to
start thinking hey there are issues in
the position i'm not saying he's worse
yet by the way right but
you're closing in on that uh
train of thought on the assumption that
if something goes wrong if i go
inaccurately suddenly there are some
issues with white's uh position once the
knight gets to f5 agreed and speaking of
slight issues maurice actually has an
update with us in another one of the
interesting games today all right
all right quick fast you get a test
which opening did this position come out
of
guaranteed everybody fails the test you
will instantly say it was indeed a
sicilian and clearly
mr maurice grand master it was
especially cough and of course we know
this was a roy lopez so again we see
structures morphing into one another the
real lopez is especially an important
one there's some openings that i
mentioned the rue lopez's one the king's
indian is another opening structures you
just should know the sicilian is of
course the other one as well you should
know these three for sure they should
have been featured in your repertoire at
some point or you at least study them
because they morph so well into each
other a real lopez could easily become a
king's indian he could also easily
become a sicilian it is absolutely the
granddaddy of openings and it was played
uh far back uh in the 15th century so we
get this opening coming from a real
lopez e4 e5 were the first two moves
with a bishop b5 line but now it is
indeed a sicilian
and especially at that well it actually
could have been out of any sicilian to
be truthful
most sicilians with e5 nadorf sicilian
could have gone into this line very very
easily
this knight now
wishes it could move
like a bishop hop over this pawn and end
up on the d5 square have a pure
advantage for white
that is where he's going to go even then
stress the call players sicilian players
think
okay so what you got that much but i
have to say this pawn on h5 does make it
feel like white might have some more how
will this knight get to that square will
it be able to go maybe d2 f1 e3 d5 will
it be able to possibly go
e1 c2 and one of these squares b4 or d5
that's interesting but the reality is
white has a light square lock and with
the light square lock it's only white
that can be better here black will play
for counter play with moves like a5 and
b4 so he needs to hurry up with stuff
like that that's typical
typical sreshnikov typical counter play
to play actually he has played the move
a5
is on the board so that is now there and
we see this position going very
interesting the other position to note
after a long think geary did play the
move queen to e5 queen t5 is on the
board and knight takes d5 was played
white has his pawn back and we are
anticipating knight to c5 and this move
will he play rook 2h4 i suspect that
topolov will play that move in this
position and this game will be
interesting those two games are super
interesting this one
not so much this one a lot of trades
have happened in the game between anand
and adams and it looks as though black
has perfectly equalized the game we
expect this one to
go the way of the carlson game and
should be
pretty much a draw just doesn't seem as
though anything can happen there but the
other games are definitely fireworks
thank you maurice and it's always
interesting to see the different styles
of chess players and of course i'm not
going to argue with the computer but
i don't think that it's actually black
that can be worse in the aronian game
simply because as a freshman of player i
know that well even if the knight gets
to d5 it's not a big deal but
specifically in this position the knight
on f3 is so terrible because he can't
reach d5 if you go through trying to get
it through e3 i always have bishop g5 to
stop you right and if you go through b
forward i already stopped you with a5 so
it's never actually going to reach d5
right so
without this knight actually getting
there i'm not really sure what white's
going to do whereas i want to go a5 b4
right i mean i'm just going to open up
this queen side all my rooks are there
um the e4 pawn feels a little
uncomfortable sometimes your f2 pawn
feels uncomfortable depending on the
position
so i mean i'm the kind of player that's
like well give me the black pieces i'm
okay really this is so wonderful really
this conversation that we're having
right now together
alejandro reminds me of one of my
favorite books
richard reddy wrote a book called
masters of the chessboard
where he explained the ideas and how
generations
uh bring
new creative
ideas to the table and remembering that
the indian defenses got their name
because they were like kind of
considered gypsy like openings you know
you you you didn't
want to go there with them it violated
the classical principles
this position
between
fabiano and lavonne was considered
unplayable for black
the reason was was back in the 1950s
there was this
match these radio matches
of the soviet union versus the united
states the usa had been gold medal
olympic winners okay
in the olympiad games leading up to
world war ii and we were considered some
of the best players in the world and we
the soviet union challenged us and we
thought that we were the favorites going
to the match and we got wiped out right
there was a
a classical game
of vassaly smithslav white versus arnold
danker black
and just as you said the knight got to
d5 and it was a wipeout it was a really
one one dimensional game play on one
goal black didn't know what he was doing
arnold denker got crushed it made such a
powerful impression
this position was just simply considered
unplayable and it's like the generations
today like my generation would say what
are you talking about alejandro you know
i don't i don't get it this is all white
right so it's just sort of like you know
how
chess evolves right absolutely i still i
you know i can't break this classical
bind that i'm in and i do like white so
after for example let us let us put that
move on the board
a5
for just a second
and let me play this move now i don't
like my knight on f3 i don't like your
rook on c4 either let me play this move
knight d2
and give you the boot
so where do you want to go c5 perhaps or
c6 or c8 or
i would say c7 looks like the most okay
okay
let me
route my knight to and here's the move
that i definitely want to play bishop g5
i don't want to let you go in there yes
so you're keeping my knight at in at bay
let me post up with my rook rook to d4
or
pardon me rook to d5
so i'm trying to eyeball this uh
what we always thought of the backward
pawn right okay
i'm hoping that you're gonna go b4
and i'll tell you why
if you do play b4 i'm hoping that after
takes takes first of all this rook hello
yeah i'm over there and secondly when i
go c4 i've got that light square control
so i don't think you want to play b4
okay immediately so how would it go
well rook c5 rook c5 is definitely an
option in this position okay i was
looking at all rook c4 again but i like
rook c5 better okay then i'll post up
you know as we say double the rooks
double trouble
yeah and you think there's a little bit
of pressure
in this position because i can create
the
normally speaking you're right you get
the knight on d5 and you're really proud
of yourself and then you discover the
knights in the way of right
of the rooks hitting the d6 pawn so here
maybe
i
i've succeeded somewhat in putting
pressure on well moving these kind of
positions i think if you take on d5 take
okay five and go queen c6 usually i'm
not really that scared you're not scared
okay and
sorry to
this wonderful battle of the classical
the modern players you're representing
the modern generation the computer
generation i'm representing the
well i don't want to say kappa blanca
generation but okay i remember deciding
the old the old fogies yeah these are
the kind of positions where i think okay
i have root b6 and i'm going to go queen
c4 at some point
why am i scared i always have bishop c1
to create counter play yeah your rooks
are great and stuff but okay now what's
your next move
well i just want to bring my bring my
knight into the game all right then this
is where i'm going to take a trade trade
position and i'm not so sure i'm
actually worse
you don't feel it though you don't you
just don't feel it
that d6 bond is not you know like
tingling is it i just go back to the
classic nimsovich once said you need two
weaknesses and you've only got one i've
always got one in this position as long
as i fall down to that pawn i think i'll
be okay but to be fair in this position
it is white that has the press and the
position just as just an insight not
just for yourself but definitely our
viewers and listeners
don't put your trust in themselves
the guy was a bozo you know
he didn't care for me from a classical
chess player
uh maurice
break in on this one how dare you talk
about nimsovich like that my goodness
the guy was a bozo
respect your elders man respect the dead
no no way in the world well he
definitely i we have had arguments about
names of for a while but i'm on
the other side i do side with nimzovich
in many ways but that's for another time
in the meantime we have some stuff
that's broken out on this board rook ad1
g6 and now the move knight to e6 and as
soon as 96 lands on the board the
engines go nuts and say black is now
winning
horrible horrible horrible for white the
winning move
you're threatening knight c7 check
picking off an exchange
go
right ahead pawn takes pawn defend this
position and the reality is there is
mate in them their hills knight takes c7
check king f7 knight takes a8 and
suddenly knight f5 check out of nowhere
and you're in big trouble
don't take the pawn because rook h4
check this beautiful bishop guarding
squares you have to go up into the board
and they're two separate mate threats
either bishop e7 bishop 86 you're
getting mated after knight to f5 check
if you don't take you are very few
squares to go to the only other move is
king to f2 and suddenly the black pieces
come streaming into the position rook h2
check and don't go here because you get
mated again rook check king over
uh and then thank you very much for a
nice little mate on that square so that
means that the only move
is king back to e1 horrible after a
knight takes and now a fork here by the
way the knight's just hanging so that's
a problem and be careful for any dangers
here in this position so that means that
going all the way back after 96 f takes
g4
how do you play how do you play the
problem is black is threatening all the
normal stuff he's threatening knight f5
he's looking for the mating ideas we
just pointed out and if you take this
pawn back now the move bishop to d7
and hello there's no way to defend the
knight it's pinned and there's no way to
protect it f5 doesn't do anything
because the pawn takes so that means you
have to have to sacrifice here on d7 and
after king takes d7
uh
you're just down in exchange
what is grishtrek doing with this move
and did he move yet did nakamura has not
moved after knight to e6 at least we're
not registering any moves but it looks
as though the engine's saying this
position looks busted 96 looks like a
horrible mistake and nakamura is sitting
there as we see there of course we get
some kind of lag with the internet image
uh being so far away in london we're all
the way here in saint louis getting this
image but still nakamura is thinking
you know he sees all the ideas there's
no question the question is is there
something hidden here
that gristrok has planned maybe
something in the exchange sack that he
thinks he should be better in that
position or his compensation
what is going on what's the mystery to
allow this clear
crushing line by nakamura i'm wondering
what he missed because it's not a
position where
i mean f takes g4 is not considerable
it's not like knight takes e7 is so
decisive right that you can take on not
consider knight uh pontex g4 knight f5
and we actually have a result
the game between vishy anan and michael
adams finished in a draw not the most
eventful
game of the day
that is true
uh it was that reverse sicilian and
things really calmed down after a
swath of minor pieces all of these minor
pieces got swapped we suddenly in a
major peace ending with seven ponds each
nothing special for either
neither player having an edge and let's
just go
for it just found out
they did the two players found a
repetition and agreed to a draw so again
not the most eventful game but from
a definite confidence booster for the
wild card player mickey adams you're
black against uh wilson former world
champion vicious clearly you've had a
lot of trouble with
mentioning the statistics yeah no i
think it's an excellent start for for
making anything i think anon wanted a
little more than this oh gosh yes oh
gosh yes i mean uh he had that beautiful
result in norway
disappointing result in saint louis he
knows that a big result in uh the london
classic gets him right into the thick of
the bonus money so yeah he wanted to
start with the bang and i think he
wanted to outplay adam slowly or
something but it totally backfired and
anna's very comfortably drew this game
never had an issue the entire game and
he'll be happy he'll be happy with his
results agreed uh if i can just flash
back to a moment to the aronian game uh
pretty much
what what we said might happen
he didn't play knight d2 by the way they
immediately rooked e5 and then we saw
the move rook c5 and lavone uh
continued
with his uh b4
press
the rook came to d5 and
this is the current position right yeah
okay
this
doesn't again i get i get this
feeling that the knight on f3
is really probably on one of the worst
circuits at the moment definitely it's
four moves away from d5 which is as far
away from d5 as it gets from any decent
position on the board but i've got it
i've got a trick in the position let me
show you my trick or my hope for trick
let's say you go queen c6 you have other
moves but at least let me just show you
this one
idea that white might be able to come up
with after c4 if you play a move like b3
just to weaken the square i've got
some
possibilities of imbalancing the game
this would be
more or less the ideal yeah because then
i could actually yeah that's
so
you know maybe
still some edge for maybe it's yeah it's
not as much i like the knight of being
on a more flexible circuit than on f3
but if i can go c4 c5 then my knight on
f3 could be turned out to be a brilliant
uh
animal and unfortunately for a ronin the
trick on taking on c3 doesn't quite work
in instead of retreating the queen oh
partly i didn't even consider it so
let's see
a little tricky sometimes but yeah
there's two ways so that this doesn't
work taking on on b2 and both rook c8
and rook b5 should be winning for white
unfortunately this doesn't work for rory
which would instantly
right get rid of the pressure exactly so
he has to settle by retreating the queen
somewhere and yeah you're right that i i
mean i'm assuming that corona will take
on
a b4 doesn't really matter where i
retreat the queen right c whether it be
c7 or b6 it makes me think a7 because a7
because you get access to the what will
be open
a file eventually okay you don't want to
play c4 and allow me to take on a3 i
don't think you really want to do that
no it was never my intention i wanted to
keep the b file closed from the black
rook so now at least i get my queen on
an appropriate uh file
i don't know so just trying to keep me
honest uh right with the downside
with the back uh backdoor check on the
on my first uh rank so c4 but still
i got some some ideas nibble
at least
and um
well visually i must say the rook
makes a a powerful impression maybe it's
one of those uh visually looks good but
not that important maybe
one of the crazy parts i've seen multi
many games where as you have mentioned
that when the bishop gets to this
diagonal
you know things really turn uh maurice
mentioned that the legal move once were
the the knight hop to d5 right now now
you want to hop with the bishop to c5
where it would be just beautiful yeah
then suddenly the whole
strategy changes we actually have
vishyanan with jennifer shahadi over in
london
hello guys this is janja hadim i'm with
this one-a-thon on on here at the london
chess classic the last
stop of the grand chess tour tell us a
little bit about your game today
um
well i think in the opening the critical
moment is when i went queen d2 somehow
uh i wasn't paying too much attention to
a5
um
somehow after that i couldn't get knight
c5 to work maybe michael had a point
that i should have gone knight c5
without queen d2
after that
it was a little bit awkward for white
but i think nothing uh really serious
was going on
and towards the end i have this little
trick with queen b7 but unfortunately
rook b8 holds everything
so you two have battled a lot in the
past how does it feel to do it here in
the grand chester stage
um nothing special i mean we we play
each other so often that
i think each individual meeting kind of
loses its significance
so what's your favorite thing about
playing in london or your favorite thing
just about london in general
well it's a
it's a fantastic city to be in um
and when i was young i used to come here
very often uh there used to be a couple
of open tournaments i used to pop by
here and then for a long time there were
just no big events in the uk
and uh i didn't get a chance to visit so
it's a time for it's a chance for me to
catch up and of course the london chess
classic has become a very important
tradition started in 2009 and
it's just a very very good tradition i
think it's what they're doing also
with the
chess in schools and communities is
wonderful and
it's good to see the uk back
actively organizing chess events what
feels different about it now that
there's the grand test tour so this is a
little bit of an extra element to the
event
um yes i think
since i'm not
particularly
doing well in the standings um
i think i should just focus on this
event and uh you know if things shape up
well then we'll take it from there yeah
i think you can win the grandchester if
you win but
i'm still i need a lot of things to fall
into place so i think it's better to
focus on this tournament than think too
much about it though all right also win
the london chess classic first right
okay thank you very much thanks
oh always envision on with fishy and on
type answers polite polite one one game
at a time right yeah and we have
actually updates in a lot of games let's
go to maurice he's got a nice
nice thing to share with us absolutely
well it's it's really funny again we're
having flashbacks all day long but i
remembered as you were about to see of
that interview i was busy looking at
that same position in it the position
that is between fabiano and aronian and
i had a flashback to this game from
1998 the game that judith pogar defeated
anan in style and in fact jennifer
although i wasn't at the lecture
apparently i was told jennifer herself
was showing this exact game during a
lecture she had over at ladies night the
the i think it was at the kingside diner
maybe or was it the world chess hall of
fame actually and she talked about this
exact game so it all came together
jennifer and anan and again we're
studying we're looking at right now
watching closely and look at the peace
distribution in this game it is exactly
what is in the kirwana game the pawn on
c5 c4 yes with the knight headed for d5
she was able to successfully maneuver
that knight to c2 and bishop g5 was not
in the position because the d-pawn was
hanging so the timing was just right
king to g7 and the in the game now
beautiful setup right it took her
forever it was only moved 25 right now
it wasn't until move 44
uh that she was able to make some kind
of movement she she actually we jump
ahead she actually got her knight to d5
took her a while to get h5 in and take
on this square and then finally the
break you talked about jazz c5 happened
in the game but not with a knight on f3
to get to e5 but the c5 break did happen
and then even after that it took her
quite some time
to get
even more out of the position but you
can see she's getting some energy here
she got a rook on c6 and now we get to
the critical position the critical
moment in the game where she was able to
flush the king out and play this
beautiful idea f4
and after e takes f4 rook h8 and in this
position anan resigned because the move
king to g7 would have been met by queen
to d4 with check and if bishop to f6
then queen takes f6 rook takes and now
rook h7 picking up everybody on the
board knight takes so he resigned
instead of letting that happen so we see
the pawn formation again the superior
pawn information we talk about beginning
back here this is that setup and if we
go to the game on question it looks as
if c4 is on the board in the game
and we have it there you have it it's
not exactly the same but it's the same
peace distribution this night can it get
to d5 will c5 happen one day get the
energy going in the position we have
those similarities yet again this time
17 moves ago a famous game from the
great judith pogar a lot of flashbacks
happening yeah what is it
we're gonna go to london very quickly as
we have the top uk player with jennifer
shahadi
thanks for that analysis i'm here with
mickey adams who is the wild card in the
third leg of the grand chess tour
welcome oh thank you yeah so how does it
feel to be the wild card here have so
many local fans is there extra pressure
um yeah but it's very nice to play in
london as well i didn't
get so many opportunities to play in
london for a long part of my career
there wasn't a lot of activity so
the london chess classic has been great
for me to get to play in london
what's your favorite thing about london
um yeah i think seeing friends here just
seeing a lot of a lot of people come in
to visit during the tournament and
that's that's very nice
now you've probably been following the
grand test tour and the stops that you
haven't been playing in um and you're
probably the only player who can't win
right because you only play one event so
who are you rooting for and who do you
think kind of deserves it if they play
like they've been playing in the first
half of the tour um well i don't think
we can tell yet it depends how everyone
plays here because it's pretty close at
the
at the top
right and today what about your game
today uh did you have any expectations
going into it and how how did you feel
about how it turned out
um well we had a lot of decisive games
recently actually uh but i think i had a
i think i got a fairly comfortable
position early on but then there was it
was pretty solid there wasn't
too much to be done but
yeah i'm happy to start with a draw with
black it's not too bad
who which game are you most excited
about
well i've been replaying all the top
guys and uh it's the tournament as a
whole i guess to play nine top guys in
one event is uh is the thing you know
it's a really big challenge
that's right it's uh it's great to see
so many other events going on here as
well like you really see the uk casting
kind of flourishing how do you feel
about the you've seen here
well i think uh i think it's going to be
very good for
for young players coming through the
london chess class again also the chess
in schools and communities so many young
players
starting off in schools and a lot of
coaching but i think it would maybe take
a little while to see the results of
that but i'm sure it's going to bode
very well for the future
totally agree well thank you very much
and good luck in the rest of your games
okay thank you
well mickey adam's definitely happy with
the start over at the london chess
classic absolutely uh draw with black
against anon in round one very nice i
don't think he's going to be as happy as
hikaru nakamura will be today against
alexander gristruck as i think that
hikaro has actually gone for this
variation with f takes g4 and
just just as we're
this 96 move turns out to be a
completely hollow threat
hikaru said execute your threat if you
choose knight takes c7 check
king f7 and we saw as maurice was saying
you can't even dare touch this rook
because knight f5 is just die
over right so e6 check was played but
now i think
came back to g8
do we need to go to g8 or can we even go
to f6 f6 scene
well let's
let's go to g8 and just leave the
opportunity option of bishop e7
what the heck is grisham going to play
here it just looks like
it looks awful
it looks really awful horrible if you
don't take the rook
the knight might end up finding itself
completely isolated by either rook a7 or
rossier rook c8 you don't want to go
knight a6 but this looks terrible and
yeah um well knight five is such a big
threat you cannot defend against it
this looks like it's just terrible
so hikaru nakamura us champion hakara
nakamura looking gold very good here
yeah i and
you know grisha was just asleep i i in
that uh interview that jennifer was
having with malcolm yeah malcolm
mentioned that uh the visa troubles you
know
there is a thing called the real world
and you hate it when you have visa
problems getting into a country it
really plays havoc with you emotionally
in your flight and all those things so
maybe um some after effects uh yeah
you're definitely not on form in this
game it seems like 96 just a total total
blackout yeah absolutely sounds like
maurice has some interesting lines here
after 96.
yeah blackout is right it's a terrible
position for him for sure and when you
see the desperation that the computer is
trying to defend with you realize this
can't be a good thing kg8 yes indeed is
the best move in the position and now
don't take this rook we've already seen
all the problems with knight f5 in the
mating lines but if you just calmly take
on g4 then he'll just as commonly play
rook to c8 and say where are you going
to put this piece it's trapped in the
position the engine is coming up with
crazy moves like rook to d7 check this
one out rook to d7 to try to defend the
position in some kind of way because
taking allowing this past pawn not
necessary let's just stay super cool
knight to
f5 threatening rook h4 again this is
going nowhere this problem is
white's problem white's got nothing
special on the board and you have to be
hyper careful to move bishop to f2
dealing with this threat okay bishop to
d6 and white pieces just look comical
trapped in the position this night on a
terrible square already desperation
you've got to kill the bishop because
the knight has nowhere to go if it
leaves and goes on the other side well
now white
black can actually play moves like rook
to h2 and come behind an attack it's
insane he's just completely dominating
the board and there are no other real
moves after king to g8 you know what the
engine's number one move is f5 when you
see moves like that your brain goes come
on now what are you trying to do and the
point being that after knight takes f5
kill this beast and then in this
position take on a8 well it's never good
news when the guy's also playing moves
like this chasing your king your king is
terrible you can always take on this
square and
pawns are fantastic if you go after a
pawn we don't think so thank you very
much move your king somewhere the bishop
is dropping all your pieces are ugly
the knight on e3 what's it doing over
there just a miserable position and
nakamura knows it i don't think
restrictive wants to sit on this board
if he's got jet lag he must be taking a
nap on a sofa somewhere because this one
isn't even worth looking at after the
move king to ga it's just a complete
disaster on the board one game that is
worth looking at however is this one
between
geary and and topolov and this line
after
knight takes on c1
rook takes on c1 knight f6 gary's got
that spidey sense you know it's trouble
let me shut these things down quickly i
need to get rid of this knight and that
was smart of him to go after the trade
instead of knight to c5 but knight c7
rook d8 queen f4 was found
by
topolov queen f4 in this position
looking to use some small edge but look
at this last move by geary g5
trade please what a move g5 bring the
trade on and he wants to trade queens
and he will this line is interesting to
look at guys because the engine's saying
definite advantage for white this double
pawn leaves an impression that the
engines prefer white here and with this
bishop there might be something to play
for in this position pretty interesting
game these two games looks like a
decisive one in nakamura and this one
topalov feeling the heat because
nakamura is right behind him in the
grand chess tour standings yeah
definitely a slight advantage here for
white it seems one of those positions
where you can play on forever without
really any fear
of black retaliating especially because
of those double dates yeah the double
pawns are never going to do anything so
you always have this chances of using
the fact that your bishop is better than
the knight in an open situation which is
exactly what we have the rooks can
always infiltrate and try to attack the
pawns and even the pawn on g5 is not
particularly happy about being on g5
right slight little nuance but at the
end of the day it's the addition of all
these details that really make black's
position worse than if for example the
phone was just on g6 yeah so a little uh
small advantages accruing right
into a nice position for our tournament
uh tour leader yeah
yeah and i think that grishak must have
missed something
because i have no idea by the way what
sasha missed i think he missed rick h3
if there's something that i want to say
he missed it must have been rook h3 i
really don't know what else it could
have been in the position here after e6
king g8 i mean of course i've been
looking at f5 for a while because it's
the only way of preventing the knight
from actually reaching the square and i
definitely don't want it reaching that
square right so e6 made sense king g at
five
and i think so you think i think he was
part of uh yeah i think he's forgotten
right i think what he forgot was that
after knight takes have five
rook rook takes f5
pawn takes knight takes a8 sometimes
even grandmasters have this instant
mechanic where like okay i think he
recaptures right and i well you cannot
recapture with black you just go rogue
the eight aha and i thought now i've got
a double threat
and maybe he thought that something like
this was possible i'm not even saying
that this works right i'm just trying to
get into his mind right on what he
missed because even this doesn't look
like it was
that great it was all good all groovy
right but you just reckoned that
three is just
he was thinking takes takes
maybe a half and now this
switches again between move rook h3
check just destroys the whole harmony
you know yeah
the line completely destroys the
position yeah i mean if you if you end
up running your king up the board
well
now
this night that we haven't captured
is way off in the corner and black has
the two bees and who knows white's king
and those jesus
is so powerful agreed agreed so you
reckon that's it but i want to say
because i always try to figure out why
people make mistakes right and
what baffles me about this one in
particular districts blunder is that f64
is super obvious because you're getting
created so obviously he calculated it
and
obviously at some point he missed
something what i'm trying to figure out
is what he missed right and it still
doesn't make too much sense to me i mean
rook h3 is as close as it gets to me to
trying to understand what he missed in
the position right but it still doesn't
seem like a move that was so difficult
that
it would have missed it they should have
missed it could you also uh having tried
to fathom
uh the blind spot uh i didn't understand
the detail okay
the computer recommends king g8 and
that's fine
but
if f5 is
white's
only
shot at staying in the game why don't we
put our king on f6
what is the um disadvantage of this
movie yeah well exactly what is the
disadvantage this move looks
more natural darn good to me i mean now
f5 really makes less sense right because
now right
no you're right about that i mean it
makes no sense
and again you you know you don't want to
take this rook because we've seen those
checkmates all and the difference
between king f6 and king g8 isn't that
necessary easy for you to say
uh but i am uh you know
why king f6 is worse than king g8 right
and i gotta say i don't know me either i
didn't
that was why i was having trouble
guessing the move king g8 because king
f6 also
looks like a kind of uh plain old
honoree kind of move you know like
keeping my king atwood well it must have
something to do with the move bishop f2
i want to say that perhaps there is some
tempo move with bishop h4 that you have
to react to or maybe an id5 at some
point good grief
i mean really looking
i don't know i'm trying to yeah yeah
you're trying to justify it as well okay
maurice help us out because we're having
trouble ourselves
well that's why we have engines guys
we explain the overall positional
features and we just let the engines do
all the work right in this position the
engines do point out that the k1 f6
is poorly placed because after king
takes g4 the way you're going to get an
edge here is to play the move knight to
f5 as in most of the lines but suddenly
that gives the knight a square to get to
so bishop f2 guards everything and now
on some rook move that we had before
that was pretty devastating earlier
suddenly the guy just sneaks out with
knight to d5 and it's uh with this check
and your king is poorly placed so this
is not the way you want the line to go
if i guess like if i go back here and
play king to g8 and the same things
happen takes on the square black now can
play for rook to c8 keeping the trap in
see if we can get that going keeping the
trap in and creating problems so i guess
if we back up even here and play that
same way king f6 rook to c8 in this
position
sorry i have to take g4 first rook to c8
in this position and now the move and
here's the main point here's the real
main point bishop to d2
out of nowhere suddenly there's this
threat hello there's no problem at all
and your king is poorly placed on this
long diagonal so that's the real reason
why the king cannot go to the f6 square
and
of course the engines you know they we
don't have to kill ourselves when we do
work here
we like to try to understand of course
all the reasons why moves are being
played yeah maybe christian forgot that
you don't have to go to f6 you can go to
g8 it's still a very suspicious line no
matter how you look at it because even
the line with knight f5 bishop f2 i was
not very convinced that white's doing
okay with the king on f6 hikaru has
found the move king g8 so right gracious
looks like he's i don't know if dead but
pretty
busted yeah maurice maurice thinks that
and by the way hikaru you know he's so
tactically gifted he's always alert to
these types of opportunities
and you know
we admire his reaction to king jia right
well he just seemed to take a deep
breath there actually like
something is not
maurice very intriguing position
guys very intriguing position on the
board has happened
after the move g5 it wasn't entirely
necessary rook e7 was also quite a good
move well at least at the same level as
g5 but g5 does do one thing it exposes
that king slightly and although black
has harmony with his forces this pawn on
g5 makes you think okay
make sure you're keeping everything
under control so
instead of trading queens the move queen
before the engine light the engines like
trading queens queen before it said now
he has a cluster take a look at that
split the board in half everything's on
this side and
somehow if he could get something going
over here would be nice but there's
nothing there to do so he played this
move queens flying around the board
first the white one now the black one
going down to b2 ignoring the threat to
his rook threatening the rook on c1 and
after rook back to a1 in the position
now rook e2 flying down into position
hitting the c5 square it looks as though
white has a very straightforward
response which he in fact did play queen
to c5 defend f2 and guess who g5 that
problem you had now threatening that
with check so 8-6 was played and now
let's get rid of this piece knight takes
on a6 we're expecting pawn takes any
second and what's going on here it looks
like white is solid he's guarding the f2
pawn black's pawn structure looks
miserable
white's only bad pawn is this one so the
feeling is white is the one who is
better here and in fact the engine's
arguing
why can't i just take your pawn looks
like a pawn what if i take it do you
have something concrete and it looks as
though black doesn't have anything
concrete because the engine's saying kg7
has the best move here still giving
white a real edge in this position but
black looking for counter play
looking though like topolov is getting
something for his enterprising play so
far uh maybe maybe it was giri who was
more enterprising you know when gary has
black he tends to try to just stay cool
and solid and draw so far he's been
playing for some very risky moves risky
at least aggressive type moves will it
work out in his favor i don't know we'll
see in a few moves he's going to have to
keep up the pressure because if the palp
does decide to take on a7 it his only
compensation is the pressure that he has
on the second rank on f2 yes so he's
gonna have to like probably triple on
that rank and hope that hope that he
creates something or at least he's able
to tie down
white's pieces enough that white can't
really take advantage of his extra pawn
but it still seems a little bit of an
unpleasant
position for black because i'm not
really sure that
you're fully compensated in this case
for your missing pawn queen takes a7
does look pretty obvious right also
just from everything you were saying
there about black's pressure on the f2
uh pawn specifically as well as you know
i don't like my opponent tripled on the
seventh or
second right you know uh the move bishop
f3 you know just to try to get rid of
that rook maybe you would play 94 not a
hundred percent sure because there is
uh some trappy move like queen e7 in
just a second you know like you're
you're hanging a lot of pieces
um but the move bishop f3 to kind of uh
i'll make sure you uh go go backwards uh
you know i like white i like white i
like liking pawns as well i'm a pond
grubber it doesn't seem like black has
enough exactly that's pretty much it on
the plus side for gary the polyp has 4
minutes and 30 seconds to make
uh eight moves and let's remember nine
moves actually and let's remember that
he doesn't have uh increments so in the
first time the first time control of
that so that's why he played kb1 which
i'm expecting will
maybe lead into a repetition
like if he plays queen a2 maybe i can go
back to
[Music]
a1 and just gain some time although i'm
not really sure that i want to play
queen a2 maybe i should just play queen
d4
try to trade off and defend the pawn
queen d4 looks maybe like a better move
yeah
um
i'm not a big fan for white of trading
off i'm not going to make fun of this
rook be one move actually well
you know if i could play c5 and get you
to trade on my terms
that would be an extraordinarily
powerful c pawn
uh before
maybe a possibility yes i don't think i
can sacrifice the exchange here
how would you do that mean
takes d4 rook takes g2 i mean you're a
little exposed i wanted to maybe see if
i could simplify the position
on the queen side because if i trade
enough pawns there that should be a
simple draw yeah but i'm not sure it's
two results right definitely two results
but i think that we've already reached
that position
where it's already two results anyway
okay that's an achievement
um maurice
we'll talk about achievements or
certainly a big achievement in the game
with nakamura and grishchuk and it looks
like some bluffing going on we know
grystrok is a poker player but i don't
think that poker stuff is going to work
here because nakamura sees very clearly
that this position is busted he played
king g8 king takes on g4 as we said
couldn't take the rook and nakamura
played a less accurate move he played
rook to a7 when rook to c8 would have
been crushing he played rook to a7
instead but he's still dominating this
position rook to d7 was found that was
the only real try here and now knight f5
threatening a maiden two well also the
bishop mind you but this rook h2 work h4
check and your king has to march up the
board actually i thought it was made in
two but it's not quite so i'm gonna play
this line out it's not quite a the same
may we're talking about but it's
certainly vicious the attack is coming
with bishop e7 your king is going to end
up all the way down the board let's just
play this line for example checking in
and now the move knight to g3 and this
poor king is stuck a little bit deep in
the position with the mate threats
coming at any moment rook g4 check or
all this is a problem as well
backing up knight f5 hitting the bishop
we don't want rook h4 to happen now
bishop to f2 and this is the key moment
bishop two has been played and nakamura
is on think here but look at all he has
to do to make life easy take the rook
and guard against the pawn going forward
that's it
now this night's hanging this pawn is
hanging
through that night no matter where the
night goes you can back up thank you
very much for your pawn you're down in
exchange for absolutely no reason this
would be the only move according to the
engine to try to fight back maybe he
says that he has some chances here done
in exchange and
yeah i see you shaking your head yes
i get it it's terrible and lost and it's
horrible it's not as bad though as if
nakamura played the move rook to c8 that
line was absolutely crushing but this is
miserable for him so this line is not it
going to that game you guys were talking
about this position
topolov has played differently with rook
to b1 as this rook is on the rank and so
aguirre is fighting but we at least have
our first decisive game it seems almost
surely although it might take a while
even if he loses the exchange he might
play a long while in that position that
is grishtrook might against against
nakamura and just nakamura just has to
find that move bishop takes d7 and
bishop e7 game over
i don't know about game over i mean
definitely black is on the driver's seat
but i feel like with time pressure
looming i mean he only has seven minutes
uh
only has seven minutes
that's like seven years but i feel it's
a position where you have to be very
precise i thought the other one was very
crushing because you just win a lot of
material but admittedly though after
bishop takes on d7 uh bishop takes d7
and bishop e7 there's not a lot to think
about in that kind of position it would
be one thing if it were weird tactics
but it doesn't seem as if he finds that
solution which he's now reaching and he
has not captured he's played the bishop
e7 immediately i didn't think it was
that clear simply because when you're up
the exchange i feel like technically if
the knights get active like let's just
say i play a couple inaccurate moves i
put a knight on e5 for nine on c4
suddenly like yeah you're up the
exchange but so what you're kingston g8
your pieces don't coordinate that well
because i'm protecting against rick h4
i'm like okay yes it's
obviously should be a win
but don't get me wrong but i don't think
it was as clear right or as easy as the
engines
as the engine let me point out that
this bishop takes d7 is only one move
bishop e7 is also winning and in fact
there are other moves that are winning
oh so well you don't have to go into
this he doesn't have to take on these d7
to me was just a simplifying line but
bishop e7 is just as winning it's a
crushing blow as well an engine saying
this is lights out it's almost like he
could just stumble forward oh that looks
good that looks good that looks good and
he'd still be fine it's not like his
advantage is dropping dramatically rook
c8 was absolutely crushing even the rook
on the back row was lights out he
decided to defend the a6 pawn what a
weird thing to do in this position with
rook a7 but
rook to c8 was absolutely crushing but
he's still crushing anyway it's just a
degree how you want to die basically
which one which way am i going to kill
you and he just has to just trip over
himself and find good moves which
nakamura with his stance right now
i think he's prepared to do yeah it's
definitely up to chris to find something
in this position but looks pretty hard i
mean bishop takes d7 looks like a pretty
big threat and i'm not
finding
any decent response i'm thinking about
the uh movie a million ways to die yeah
that is you just have your choice
uh just flashing for a second on the
very strategical fight between fabiano
and lavonna rooney and it looks like
lavone has managed to
equalize because the pawn on d6 without
the heavy rooks on the board
is not a
weakness and we mentioned before if
black ever gets his bishop on this
diagonal he's got constant pressure on
f2 it's very hard for white to achieve
progress so i just think that
uh this game is actually being shut down
so going back again to the
uh pardon me the hikaru nakamura game
he's played bishop e6 maurice
thoughts big news big news in the game
with geary and topolof topolovin
terrific time pressure missed a shot
he's not going to be losing but he looks
like he's overlooked this move that's
thrown away his advantage after rook to
b1 with two minutes to make 10 moves
queen to d2 he played bishop to f3
thinking that this would be okay trying
to chase the rook off the second row
only to have knight e4 get splashed down
immediately on the board suddenly f2 is
hanging and that advantage off this
bishop that we were talking about is
going to disappear and he's spending a
lot of time burning a lot of clock time
in this moment
to play what looks like really his only
move it's his only move is to take the
knight and he has not played it he has
played queen takes a7 which is just a
blunder total blunder after knight takes
on f2
knight takes f2 is simply winning
according to the engines bishop takes on
e2 knight takes with check and now if
you try to go after this night with king
up well thank you very much for this
piece and you are going to get crushed
king to g2 will be forced and now hello
welcome to this wait a minute i think
there's even better no this is the right
move rook to d2 check and suddenly black
is back in business black has four pawns
the queen will always be a problem guess
he can give away his queen and hope he
survives this position maybe there was
something that i missed earlier here
oh actually here the right move sorry is
rook to d2 wow that's nice rook to d2 is
the best move this is mate in seven
according to the engines this is out you
can't stop the mating ideas that are
coming with queen h5 you'll be throwing
away pieces the engines as the engines
do rook c8 and sacrificing everything
because this threat is too huge and
nothing to stop it
total of with only a minute and a half
on the clock ticking down and he is dead
lost if uh he's not ticking right now
actually his blacks move if if he finds
knight f2 does grishchuk the game's over
it's just devastating knight takes f2
with all the tactics topolov has
you know time pressure makes fools of us
all that quote is as appropriate as ever
right now because knight takes f2 and
look at geary feeling relaxed this will
be a disaster in round one
topolov the leader of the grand chester
going down in round one with nakamura
winning his game
what an amazing development right away
here at the london chess classic well
but i'm really made your swing yes i
understand your confusion because i am
as well knight takes f2 bishop takes
bishop takes knight takes we understand
we can't go after they're not clear so
so now the question is why aren't we
playing king f1
and uh i'm assuming there's something
uh i didn't know whether it was d6 or d5
but some rook lift maybe it's this that
uh vessel and missed but even in this is
really that bad i mean we can always
give up the queen which i guess is very
ugly you mean with a check and a capture
but that's ugly i agree that this
doesn't look good for white at all right
actually guys so that we can get right
up to pace it's really interesting that
gary has to find some spectacular ideas
because right here he's
this is you're correct the critical line
this move according to the engines
actually loses horribly because of this
check and after the king moves the queen
can come over and and guard this square
if rook f6 now he can play this move and
it's white who's just fine your attack
doesn't work this king is going to take
there's not enough time to get
everything the rook wants to be down
here not on this square and white is
coming in behind
with the rook coming back if the king
gets flushed out so this is not good the
key move and it's geometric it's
beautiful after king f1 the geometry of
the board the knight is guarding the
dark squares you need this queen to
guard the light squares
that's the killer blow queen to d5
and queen h1 sneaking in computer s
definitely and now you're in big trouble
as to what to do because that's mate
that's a mate threat the only move is to
step so you can run no you can't the
d-file is covered so guess what it's
just a straight chafing attack queen
down bishop f1 and now queen to f3 and
look at the king i mean you look at this
you
you feel like you got problems when you
see this move but will geary find queen
d5 i mean that's important he has to see
queen d5 coming from knight takes f2
i get the feeling he's going to say that
should be the line i play i should play
knight takes f2 i'm going to be fine if
that other line's not made but but guess
what if he plays it if he walks into
this position after king f1 everything
else is losing only queen d5 wins he's
down a rook he's down a rook only queen
d5 even keeps him in the game any other
move loses by a long shot so he must
find this sequence or else he's busted
so geary under pressure having to find
an attack right now will he find it with
the seconds ticking down and a win for
him would be huge and i can't imagine
how he'd feel
coming out of this game not winning if
if he doesn't find these moves but
doesn't it
look at this i mean a strange situation
like uh vessel is forcing his opponent
to win because after bishop f3 if you
don't play knight f1 why don't you lose
it yeah i mean you could just resign the
thing about this position is you don't
play knight takes f2 you just lose right
what else can you play here if we play
but
as
i understand it he did play knight takes
f2 yeah as i understand it it's so easy
uh from white's point of view especially
yeah i mean come on you're down you
you're you're you're so short on your
clock right if you don't see queen d5
which is so difficult it's a very
difficult move to find i i wouldn't
doubted all that vessel and had seen
rooks he ate and queen e7 reasons this
is really what's going on this is a
thrill what's going on gary's going for
the queen
did he he's going to look like he's
reaching will he find the move no i
found that he found it of course he
and guys while he's found he's getting
up look at that confident he knows that
he's crushing him right now queen b5
beautiful geometrics and he's found the
move and
let's add while he's winning that game
nakamura has blown his completely he has
taken a win and thrown it away alejandro
you are right he found a bad move in
this position he played instead of doing
that attacking line that we saw with
knight f5 he played this one rook h7
ugly as ever i mean knight f5 could have
gone back but in time pressure nakamura
on my clock with only 49 seconds to go
maybe his clock says something different
but grishook now just has to find a move
like knight to c4 bringing his piece
into the game and the whole game is up
for grabs only a slight edge for black
but not that crushing edge rook c8 would
have given or even the capture on d7
would have given
here also knight f5 would have given he
has just managed to fritter it all away
and grishak is back in the hunt and look
at his posture nakamura it's not the
look of a man who's super confident
knowing he's got to win he will be
devastated if he does not win this game
if he loses oh man forget it but it
looks like the game is turning and he's
full of uncertainties nakamura maybe he
still has some kind of perpetual with
knight f5 kind of ideas but he has to be
careful that he doesn't overpress
because he's no longer winning as easily
as he was before yeah 49 seconds
dramatic turn i didn't realize that was
so hard 49 seconds that's wow incredible
yeah how many moves i beg your pardon
and there we go okay instantly play
knight f5 check he's at least going to
repeat a couple of times if he can yeah
yeah exactly
but the question is he goes king g3 is
he really going to push for a win here
he has 45 seconds to make a decision
either he takes the draw now
or he risks giving grishok the option of
playing on and not having the perpetual
is nakamura winning that's what he has
to decide maybe he sees something that
we don't
and he's going to try to push he might
just go for the draw though which i
think is what he's going to do it's a
practical decision with only 30 seconds
left and nothing immediate to be seen
exactly it's yeah he's shaking his head
but he's going to take the draw by the
way by the way oh he's suffering on his
board bishop h5 was played in the game
with the other players and we see here
they're going on giri and topolov as the
move has been repeated so we're seeing a
draw happen there giri now has made in
nine the he played bishop h5 the topalov
and that move is death and it's easy too
nakamura took the draw so that one is is
done and now queen h1 check if we jump
to this one as nakamura is just
disgusted and we'll be more disgusted
when he's done but this one is too easy
check and queen g2 check and look at
this king i mean it's just
pot shot at the king in this position of
king to e1 now rook to e8 and now king
only move to d1 and now knight f2 and
here's where it's happening badly for
him he actually has to take this piece
has to why because if you try to run to
the other side of the board simply
knight back to e4 and that's going to
combine with the beautiful harmony of
the queen there's nowhere to go anywhere
you go running up the board is going to
allow queen d2 check and march on the
other side of the board and it's all
just direct as you're now mated you have
to throw your queen in the way and the
game is over so this is easy after
knight f2 check
going back to here the engines give this
ridiculous move queen takes queen takes
and we know this is out this is death so
a crazy turn of events geary's going to
actually win the game and he's kind of
looking at scans like oh and he has
played a few of those moves he's there
with the queen on g2 he just has to play
rook and he's playing it he's not going
to miss anything right now rookie 8 king
d1 and we're expecting knight f2 and
topolov will be history yep pretty much
that's the game
wow
what a turn of events uh
this
yes of course of course yeah he might
resign on the next move and here it is
coming on the board knight f2 look at
that confidence play yeah like the way
he uh with no time on the clock though
he's not resigning just because he has a
little time on the clock but knight is
coming back to e4 and i think this is
adrenaline yeah i think this is moving
forward adrenaline yeah that he's
playing
so there he goes
and yeah
just resign here vessel and will uh stop
the clock he started to shake his head
each you know when you're trying not to
act like you're losing maybe maybe the
guy might miss the moves but
now he look now he's has the look of a
desperate defeated man and he knows it's
over and now he's even looking disgusted
you saw that look on his face right
there and anish look at him he's just
waiting for the handshake he's like okay
dude come on just extensively calm what
a great win with the black pieces
absolutely out of nowhere actually out
of nowhere were we saying two results
yes we were we forgot about that there
was a third result
wow the third result is called time
pressure time pressure indeed and while
nakamura
losing half a point basically and time
pressure the pilot was saying i don't
want to call it a full point because he
wasn't winning but
at least half a point right not so we've
seen some real turn of events taking
place as early as round one right uh and
uh for our tournament leader vessel and
topolof
tournament he's not the tournament
leader he's wrong
and there it is
yeah
resignation as topalov goes down that
was spectacular by the way the way black
just came in and hammered him into
submission for that small mistake of
allowing well big mistake it turns out
along knight takes f2 huge mistake well
it's a difficult variation to calculate
about like hello i mean this is
i mean when vessel and played the move
bishop f3 he thought he had the game
coal right he's winning without this
queen d5 not only is queen d5 the only
move to keep black in the game
shockingly it wins right and there are
so many defenses that he had later on
that still didn't work like for example
instead of going bishop h5 which
admittedly i think was refuted
relatively easily with this knight f2
maneuver right i mean he had moves like
king e1 right that i was like still it
doesn't look obvious i mean the queen on
a7 is doing such a fantastic job
defending you have to find moves like
queen h1 bishop f1 queen f3 i'm like wow
this is very hard to find exactly and
these rooks on c1 and b1 your whole rook
ahead but they're not doing anything to
stop well guys you're you're talking but
you should show that on the board those
lines are so beautiful sure worth doing
what a spectacular finish happens in
that game
incredible play so the point that we
were saying is that that's when we go
into this uh we have some shahadi with
actually hikaru nakamura over in london
all righty
hello guys i'm here with our us champion
nakamura very nice outfit you got on
today
what was the occasion
i think everyone dressed up as first
round major tournament so
it's just how it goes
so what do you think about today's game
um well i don't know i mean i think i
was a little bit lucky in the opening um
alexander plays king h2 move which
i don't know if it's a novelty or not i
feel like i've seen it before but at any
rate i didn't think i
played the right way i didn't think c5
was necessarily best but um
okay i think they're in the middle game
alexander made a few bad moves um
and i was able to get in this f5 move
and after that i think i'm probably much
better um
and then i basically i played the wrong
order i mean i should have just taken
this pawn on g4 instead of going g6
first um
because basically as it turns out in the
game or at least i think um
there wasn't quite enough to win it
looks so much better but it's just not
simple so if i'd gone the other way i
would have just had a lasting advantage
whereas i thought i possibly could have
won on the spot with the way i played
with g6 but uh i mean sometimes things
don't go your way uh
that's just life that's right you look
pretty composed you're not too
disappointed
oh it's that's that's how it goes
sometimes i mean you when somebody loses
something i mean today was a draw but uh
okay i was black so it's certainly not
not the end of the world
so london i've read before that you said
you love this city what is it that you
like so much about london
um i just like the atmosphere it reminds
me a lot of
new york city actually there's a lot of
different areas a lot a lot of good food
especially you know ethnic food indian
iranian and so forth obviously here in
kensington um and it's just a great city
obviously there are a lot of tourist
attractions as well so i really like it
um
of course the drawback is it's too
expensive you know the currency exchange
rate and also uh it gets dark much too
early but otherwise it's a great city
and you know i enjoy being here we'll
just win the grand chess store pay for
all
but we'll see we'll see i'm not thinking
about money right now
all right thank you
um thanks guys back to the studio
thank you jennifer
well i think uh hikaru just didn't
realize what a great advantage he had i
think he felt it but because he didn't
find it he now is
questioning his intuition right but i
think that he's spot on and when he sees
this on a computer he'll say rook ca
simple move why did i uh convince myself
that rook a7 was better because there's
two choices right
but
this game this this huge turnaround game
between vessel and topolov
and anish geary when
this moved bishop f
pardon me
when bishop when
toppolov grabbed the pawn on a7 i'm sure
he felt he was winning
knight takes f2 bishop takes h2 knight
h3 king f1 queen here this is where you
have mentioned
that
a much more combative move was king e1
and then suddenly after check bishop f1
okay do your worst i'm a rook ahead
and this
quiet little move i mean it's almost
painful brutal is right you just play
queen f3 you post up you're ready to
grab this pawn on g3
and rookie one check and
you know this would have been much more
challenging uh that definitely is green
queen f3 yeah for uh vessel and topology
actually what's cool about this position
is that the threat is is to take on g3
and after king e2 knight f4
is mate so you can't just make any
random move let's just make a random
move queen uh b4 yeah and now to take
with check king e2 and then this nice
show of geometry uh is just made all
around so that is the key threat in the
position and the problem if we go back
again just to this moment if you try to
guard against the g3 pawn well how do
you do it queen to c7 well then you
release and allow queen f2 mate so
there's no way to
get get a defense of this pawn now let's
let's go back again if rook if knight f4
is the mate what about rook to c4
here
that's a lot to calculate actually right
rook to c4 is interesting and after
knight g1 maybe and now that's
winning the queen at least and with
extra pawns everywhere that's like
crushing analyze as well there's
something better and now it's just over
so that's the key but the key was to get
to the up to that square f3 and then
know everything is good after that i
broke down it was a rook sack and it
just comes out i still need some
explanation on what's going on after
bishop e2 wasn't this so clear i mean
i'm sure there's a win but
if i play bishop e2 here bishop e2 of
course black can go for a perpetual so
he feels very safe but
i've got uh rookie eight no
you got ideas but am i right
is it is it time to resign sometimes
every sign is what i want to know if
like rookie 8 i have rook b2 maybe um it
looks pretty bad i agree but
yeah what does that mean
where's the hammer blowing queen g3
check
here and after king f1 rook e3
no sorry i i saw my rook on the wrong
square yeah so i need my rook on the
file first right so maybe rookie
or
yeah but now i can go through the d file
i'm not so sure and then you can write
so this is what i'm saying i mean i'm
sure that black's winning somehow i can
probably even play
i don't know but you're just saying that
that this is far more challenging far
more challenging oh wait a minute go
back let's go back again now that we're
not using the engine since we're having
a little bit of fun what if what if uh
bishop e2 queen takes g3 and then the
rook goes up to d
after king f1 queen g3 king f1 and rook
d6
how's that
i mean of course these are positions
which may be black's winning but there's
no queen e7 anymore because we've got
mates on f2 and g2 right
f2 and g1 thank you very much yeah so
yeah this might be
the killing blow i wanted to play rook
c6 but it doesn't work because i have uh
still checkmate on f2 or g1 anyway like
you're thinking oh i'll trade off you're
right
but still checkmate everywhere exactly
exactly that critical point you made the
critical point is alejandro when you're
in the attacking mode
whenever you find a perpet
you know you can play that line right
it's like okay if i'm not winning it
looks like i'm winning i should find a
win but if i always have queen h1 bishop
f1 queen f3 then i'm perfectly safe
playing the line and it's his
responsibility to find moves remember
that black is in trouble after bishop f3
black is black is in danger so black
needs to find a move so if you just find
a line that says queen d5 i'm looking
good there's a perpet at the end of it
then i'm good to go what i really was
impressed by though was after bishop f3
landed on the board after some thought
geary played knight e4 if we go back
uh to no back back the other way
we go back a couple of moves to this
moment when bishop f3 landed on the
board there was some thought it was like
this nice squeeze blue bishop f3 i got
you now move your rook back and suddenly
instantly 94 landed on the board and
that seemed like it shocked
just suddenly this move was on the
border and instead of just killing the
knight
and just saying okay fine the night goes
he decided to continue down the line he
didn't have any time to think about the
change in the position because he was in
so much time pressure that he decided to
take this pawn fatally so and ended up
going down in just
brilliant body blows after knight takes
f2 and it's such a weird psychological
moment at that point when you go 94 and
it's like okay i can draw the game i can
take on you for him bail right or
is my opponent miscalculating right it's
so difficult with a minute and 20
seconds your king's wide open right and
it's like do i believe him do i not
believe him and there are certain
players that even if they don't see
anything for their opponent they will
take the night just say
i trust you you're a super grandmaster
if you bluff me it's okay right but
they'll take the night and there are
some players like the paulo that are
like
show me right right and one of the show
me guys as well unfortunately
i don't see it it's not there as far as
i'm concerned you're gonna have to beat
me but you know the truth is if you play
chess and you're an experienced player i
don't care what your strength is you've
played a position where you stand really
well and you force your opponent into a
combination and it's rebounded and it
works and it's the worst feeling like
because you literally force your
opponent to beat you
you know and i'm sure vessel and
you know he's had losses like this we
all have we're following him still yeah
that extra painful i mean wow and for
anish
what are we to win what a win from a
position that honestly i don't think
even he was considering
was going to be a win at some point and
i wouldn't be surprised that at the end
of the day he
[Music]
is in fact surprised himself that he was
winning after queen d5 because i think
he found a perp and he was like okay
this is good enough i'll figure it out
later exactly i don't think he had
necessarily calculated
but okay it was a brilliant win i mean
it's 94. such a nice move and actually
we have a result another result final
game of the day
with the locked positions of the pawns
and the reduced material i'm going to go
ahead and assume this was a draw and
indeed it was they have shake
there's been the handshake yeah and this
is actually kind of a funny position no
and
no way for either side to invade with
their king oh absolutely i remember
there was actually a rule a tournament
rule because we had some situation like
this where one of the players lost on
time
and the other player was said
no i don't lose on time because there's
no way to win the position it was like
right
there's no material on the board to mate
there is he was trying to
make such a claim and i think it was
validated actually well it is validated
because you have to prove that through
legal moves that you can win you can
checkmate your opponent somehow so for
example you have a knight against a rook
there is actually a configuration
operation a cooperation checkmate which
you can arrange but in this position
even if black plays the very worst
possible moves to cooperate and allies
on a loss you can't so yeah
so the the the it was upheld that no no
uh yeah you didn't lose it you didn't
lose on time right
wow why did
the most
important tournament of the year and uh
all the thrills and spills that we would
expect well one black victory which came
through
just blush head i mean the king
to paul's king he did not feel good
check made it on the middle of the board
after a rook sacrifice very nice win for
gary definitely a disappointing round
for nakamura i think that he as he said
he got everything he wanted from the
opening and was unable to finish his
opponent off we got four draws today
definitely an interesting
set of uh games but i think geary's game
takes the
crown no question about it and we have
tomorrow's pairings as we will have an
earlier round tomorrow since it's the
weekend
we'll be starting at 8 00 am central
standard time 2 p.m in london the white
pieces we have the tournament leader a
niche gear the only player to win today
against michael adams levon aronian will
try to put some pressure on vishy and on
magnus carl said in a well what's become
a classic matchup against fabiano
caruana one of the players that he has
most trouble against hikaru nakamura
will try to bounce back from a
disappointing result by playing maxine
bashiala graf and topalov who was the
only loser of today's round playing
against probably the luckiest player of
the round
alexander grisham
exciting battles for tomorrow two hours
early two hours early yeah
well alejandro well lovely broadcast
it's really great being with both of
yourselves uh maurice final thoughts
we've still got a couple of oh sorry oh
sorry sorry we're waiting for them in
london as we try to get the players to
just finish their games hopefully we can
get right hopefully we can get geary uh
up on i would really like to know his
thoughts uh going into this queen d5
move we're gonna be able to see if we
have him
and we actually have fabiano karana our
own american player with jennifer
shahani in london
[Music]
thanks guys i'm with fabiano caruana and
you guys recognize this symbol over
there don't you
i'm so fabio welcome to the show
were you were you so happy with your
opening today
i thought it's more or less equal
he seemed pretty well prepared but
i think he had a simple way to equalize
and he started getting a bit too
um extravagant and
he could have played c6 early on and he
was and then i was a bit better but um
i'm not sure if i had ever had anything
serious
so you're satisfied with your play in
today's game um
yeah maybe i had chances to cause more
problems but more or less i think it was
a normal game
how do you like playing in london
uh yeah i like it a lot i
played here a couple times and i always
enjoy staying in the city it's
it's one of the most interesting cities
um
and yeah usually i have a chance to go
around and decide to see it
what's the one thing you like to do if
you have one afternoon or one night off
in london what what sightseeing
i mean last year i i just went around i
saw buckingham palace
um i saw that i have london but i i mean
i don't know if there's one thing that i
do
too much to do probably on london
and uh how does it feel the london chess
classic being part of the grand test
tour um what does that add to the event
um
well there's uh i mean there's the added
uh importance of the final standings
which i
in all likelihood i won't be a part of
but
um i think i still have my chances
um
yeah so
i mean it's just it's interesting to see
who will finish the top three overall
who's your pick
i have to say myself
i mean i don't have many chances but uh
if i do well here i
i can still finish in the top three
right that's right always got to keep
the confidence up right i mean after all
you just uh just won the the blitz match
versus the one of the ambassadors
player in the world uh hicaro so feeling
confident coming into this right yeah i
feel pretty good about my chances all
right thank you fabiano carolina um back
to you guys in the studio
lucky recap the results of the day as we
have
um
an interesting round i think it was a
good start definitely wrestling topolo
floss with the white pieces slightly
unexpectedly in time pressure against
anish giri after a fabulous sacrifice
alexander grischak with the white pieces
can consider himself lucky to have
survived against hikaru nakamura in a
berlin that went all kinds of wrong
in this fashion of sicilian maxine
bashir lagrav drew against magnus
carlson again that was relatively even
all throughout fabiano caruana
as you said maybe a very slight amount
of pressure against levon aronian also
ended in a draw and a game that never
really got off the ground was vishyanan
drawing against michael
adams and uh speaking of level one
neronian we actually have him with
jennifer shahadi in london
hello guys thank you i'm here with
lavonna ronian who won of course the
last stop of the grand chester in st
louis so you're going to keep it going
here in london
hopefully how do you feel about today's
match against fabiano
it was one of those games
that are very interesting for the
players
but not too interesting for the audience
really d5
i mean we were so excited about the d5
square oh yeah okay
i thought
it was okay all along but at one moment
instead of
equalizing and just playing c6 i thought
to get a bit ambitious
because i was up on time and i got to
regret this decision
at what point did you feel like you're
in the most trouble of all the game
yeah i wasn't sure about when
i mean uh
he played knight a2 i probably have to
go for this and then he can
take on d6 i wasn't really sure what's
happening there because it's so
complicated
so
not that i was really worried but i was
more
you know i couldn't see what happens
there so
i i was curious
so you decided to stop calculating and
just go for it because you didn't want
to get into time pressure or something
like that
i don't really have a big choice there
so
it was more or less forced
well what do you think about this
tournament in general the london chess
classic and playing in london i think
you told me this is a city that you
really like oh who doesn't right
yeah i love being in london
when it doesn't rain so so
far we're blessed with a nice weather so
as long as the weather is good i think
the games will
i mean be interesting
oh there's a correlation between the
weather and the games like a positive
correlation
i mean interesting for me not
not for the others because i like
you know to uh
walk around and enjoy uh
being in a big city when i play chess
that's right how many hours a day before
the game do you walk around are you like
a flaniar however you pronounce that
word
no not really i i walk around maybe an
hour before the game okay
since i mean the game start fairly late
at eight o'clock i had the time at four
o'clock i had the time to
um
go some places well at least i didn't
ask you how many hours a day you study
jazz
yes yes well i'm thankful for that all
right thank you guys lavon he is doing
great in the grand chester he won the
last stop in st louis so we'll send it
back up to you in the studio
well interesting round i think we have
uh some final remarks by maurice
maurice
i just wanted to say before we go to
maurice one of the things that i really
uh was curious
it's unusual in that game of cardioana
and levon and levon did mention it first
you had to move knight h2 and then on
the other side of the board you have to
move knight a2 which is what
yeah the strange duality they're going
on maurice
well there were certainly a lot of funky
night moves played today no one uh more
crushing than knight takes f2 in the
game with geary and topalov it was a
very exciting round despite a couple of
nondescript draws but to see the players
going for it nakamura certainly will not
be happy after he sees the computer
evaluation of how he should have won
quite easily but giri guys has not lost
the game on the entire grand chess tour
and though people snicker at the fact
that he makes so many draws hey today he
goes out the gate with a victory we'll
see how he keeps it up or if he keeps it
up as the tournament goes on but he is
now the youngest player in the
tournament the tournament leader i
believe for the first time in both of
these events and this being the third
event and
i think he's got a strong chance if he's
confident he can make it happen of
course it's still just round one but
it's good to go out of the gate with a
bang i can't wait to see tomorrow's game
as this tour continues
thank you maurice well and thank you for
joining us here at the broadcast it was
a pleasure and we will see you two hours
earlier tomorrow as we start at 2 p.m
london time 8 00 a.m here in the central
west end and also it's 8 am it sounds
scary vicky
and we'll see you tomorrow thank you for
joining us
[Music]
well the winner came along
settled in real strong
and i could not
you